well hello uh hello everybody welcome to the show
welcome to 2021 and uh we're about to get into
the i'm not a gm tournament i'm your host
grandmastermon hamilton and i'm joined by
andrea botes my co-host for today hi andrea hello
guys how's it going i'm on pretty good pretty good
i'm feeling great this morning i have to admit
i'm starting off 2021 waking up earlier than i
ever did in 2020 me too actually i've been trying
to put in some healthier habits so yeah let's make
20 21 off to a good start yep yep cheers to that
um and this tournament is probably one of the more
exciting ones for me i i just love like these
entertaining type of events that chess.com puts
on it's the i'm not a gm tournament and as i like
to describe it it's people in this tournament are
talented enough that it's really really high level
chess that people can follow but there's also
enough blenders that i think it makes it highly
entertaining yeah i think the speed matches are
the most fun and i'm especially excited because
my sister will be competing and we were training
together yesterday to beat greg but now she's
on her own so curious to see how she's gonna do
up against greg yeah and you've you've just uh
highlighted the match up and that's uh exactly
right today it's gonna be international master
greg shahadi facing off against uh women's feuding
master alexandra botez and you mentioned that
she's gonna be on her own today you've done maybe
some some sister prep the other day but uh the
interesting thing about this match uh people can
already uh guess there is a rating mismatch greg
is the the favorite by rating and so alexandra is
starting with 15 points handicapped so she starts
the match up 15-0 and then the match is basically
a race can greg you know collect those 15 points
and then some over the course of the match or is
alexandra just gonna run away with it so what do
you think of this odds format which is the kind of
the first time we've seen this in this tournament
and in these match formats i think it's going to
be very interesting because alex especially that's
why she was trying to memorize those lines because
the rating gap was so different so i'm really
curious if this will make it equal odds or not
yep so we'll have to see about that guys uh and
we'll be reminding you throughout the event about
that that handicap but keep that in mind uh
alexander starts with 15 points and and with
that let's let's jump into the you know precise
format of this match and the entire uh uh i'm
not a gm tournament so um as you can see the the
main bracket is just single elimination knockout
which you'll be familiar is the style for these
uh speedchest championship type of matches and
speaking of those scc formats uh it's going to
have a five plus one blitz time control there's
gonna be a three plus one blitz time control
and one plus one bullet chest so uh first of all
andrea what do you think of those three formats
does that make it like a pretty pretty balanced
match do you think either player will have an
advantage in one of these controls yeah i'm really
excited for you know the last few bullet matches
um i think the blitz i don't know i don't watch
too many um speed tournaments so it's always
very interesting because alex for example her big
strength is bullet and dirty flagging i don't know
if greg will be as speedy but that's my favorite
part of speedchest the very last few quick seconds
and minutes yep yep and that is probably going to
be very very important for the match overall
i mean i think alexandra would be maybe a lot
happier if she could get 75 minutes of bullet
chest instead of yeah the set of the 25 minutes
that uh they've got there but we'll see how that
plays out but you guys will be very familiar with
that format from previous editions and um well as
you can see the winner of the match advances to
the next bracket and what are these guys competing
for well let's talk a quick sec about the prizes
um these guys are competing for ten thousand
dollars in prizes uh in total there's the round
of 16 there's the quarterfinals the semifinals
and the finals and you can see the breakdown there
the winner the round of 16 250 dollars and then
they advance to the quarterfinals and the other
interesting thing is that uh the rest of the money
is split by win percentage so uh all i'm seeing
based on this andrea is that uh your sister she's
already starting out with some money she's got 15
points on the board yeah she has some pretty
good chances here to win some nice prize money
so that's not too bad um everyone is gonna have a
good time get a good match and then obviously if
you progress in this tournament you collect more
and more prizes um so let's take a quick look at
the bracket as well you're probably wondering you
know this sounds like an exciting matchup to start
things off brag against alexandra but uh who else
do we have in this tournament and as you can see
from the bracket here you know have a lot of names
that you might recognize from maybe the previous
edition of the i'm not a gm tournament but there
are also some names that i think people will be
more familiar andrea from just the streaming world
um yeah how that's changed so many names stand
out there to you that you recognize of course
almost almost all of them i was going to say
we have erica rosen we have even some younger
girls getting into streaming like carissa yip
a less alessia who's been streaming for a long
time obviously levy lots of big streamers here
that i'm very excited to see yeah and of course we
can't forget danny wrench i was gonna say you know
he's easily forgettable but he is he is in the
tournament and he's uh facing off against lawrence
trent as you can see over there so i know there's
a lot of levy fans uh in the chat as i can see
um so he's gonna have a match up against james
canty as well there's as you mentioned a lot
of other streamers so i think it's just gonna
be a nice mix of players that were in the last
edition of tournament plus a lot of new streamers
uh that that a lot of people are fans of yeah
it'd be a lot of fun do you think the streamers
will have a higher percentage of wins mainly
because they're more used to speed chess and
bullet well as a streamer myself andrea i'd
like to think that that's the case you know we
streamers we got to stick together so we need some
some advantage at least here's to hoping
here's to hoping that we can just uh
let's us streamers we have an advantage somewhere
in speeches exactly yeah so i'm definitely uh
definitely secretly rooting for some some
streamers to do well but you know as as everyone
can see there from the bracket uh you know a lot
of your favorites are gonna be in this event um
it's a pretty long long event uh many matches so
uh there'll be lots of lots of time to cheer for
your favorites yeah anything can happen we have
like three hours of of speech so lots of games
today yep um and the game should be starting
in in a couple of minutes uh andrea we can see
the the players are on cam what do you make of
the let's call it the first impression we got
alexandra and greg uh who who sort of wins
the the outfit battle so far i have to say
every time i i did one match actually where me
and greg we're a team against alex and he always
pulls out these hats i'm a big fan of the hats so
i say he's the winner just for his nice hat game
and are you saying that while watching your
sister do some curls there um yeah because
i i mean alexander is really trying to win over
the hearts of the crowd right now she came into my
room asking for the dumbbell and i didn't really
understand how it would come into use into the
the speed match but you know preparing you know
like they say a healthy body healthy mind so
very important every doesn't every don't you do
this before every chess match well i was gonna say
the fact that your sister came in early in the
morning and said can i can i grab the dumbbell
for my speed chest match and you didn't find that
weird i i think that just goes to show how normal
things are you know in the bow tez household
there yes of course um but i i agree i like the
uh i like the hat from from greg uh although all i
see on the scoreboard right now is the guy's down
15 points he seems pretty confident for a guy's uh
getting crushed in this match so far yeah then i'm
curious what he i'm gonna enter when we interview
him i'm very curious what he thinks about this
because originally this was this was the last
minute well not very last minute change but
i thought alex could maybe even take him
on without the point odds so who said
maybe she doesn't need it or maybe that's just
the the natural born hustler in her she she knew
she knew she could take greg and she pretended she
hustled away exactly she needed some 15 points so
that's like not bad at all but yeah it is
a points odds match we're starting with 15
points uh for alexandra and then the rest of
the match just proceeds and scores normally
see the chat is already uh already on that 15
points so we'll we'll see i i think that it is
going to make things more exciting um at the end
of the day greg is the um the stronger player
but yeah as you mentioned alexandra very
very tricky and very used to streaming and
playing online so hopefully that that pays
off here yeah i like tease a bit i mean greg
is do you know his rating alex was telling me he's
around 2700 which would be a huge rating gap so in
the end i do think it's pretty fair but you know
of course i'm gonna cheer on alex a little bit
yup no this is a completely unbiased commentary
booth absolutely there's nothing to see here
greg definitely has a very high rating on
chess.com and uh he was in the previous edition
of uh the i am not a gm tournament and i think
he uh he made it to probably i think it was at
least the semi-finals so he's he's definitely
one of the favorites to do well here but looks
like he's having a good time he's got the got the
hat on and he seems to be uh in good spirits yeah
greg is always very positive when i played with
him as my teammate it was so much fun he's very
positive she keeps his head up the entire match
even if you're even when we're losing a few games
and with that attitude we've managed to pull a
win so i think it was all because of greg yep
yep and how's the how's the chat feeling about our
our competitors here do they agree with you that
that greg won the outfit battle maybe there's
maybe there's more alexandra fans in chat i'm
not sure but um you know we have to judge
this fairly who's going to win the match but
also right now yeah i see we have a poll going on
and oh most of the chat thinks 15 points might be
too much of a handicap but i don't know greg is
pretty strong they might be underestimating him
yep well the one thing about uh
people have to remember about the
five minute portion andrea is that it actually
goes really slowly right like a five minute game
with one second increment don't forget guys it can
actually go like you know 15 minutes for for one
game so that portion can really take a long time i
think that greg is comfortable with this handicap
because he's hoping to make it up in bullet so if
he's wrong about that then it could he could be
totally wrong for the match yeah not even bullet
one thing we were discussing yesterday when alex
and i were training with hammer was like even when
he would get in better position straight from the
opening with greg's experience in the longer time
control he could probably easily outplay in the
end game so i think even in a longer time control
he's even more favored yep and and i've just been
told kind of a funny funny bit of information
that it was actually suggested that the the let's
say the handicap instead of 15 it was actually
supposed to be 12 points and then greg was like
12 points you got to be kidding me and he said
make it 15. so that's a little bit of confidence
from greg johnson go chat yeah everyone's
saying that it's too much of a handicap no greg
is feeling confident about this yeah he wanted
this he wanted the uh i like the confidence yep
that's good and i think that the uh yeah
that's a big big alpha move there by uh by greg
yeah we'll see if you'll regret it maybe
those three points will be decisive who knows
and i'm just following the players here
because you know what uh andrea the games
have uh just got underway i'm so excited for these
games because we studied these lines and greg has
some like favorite sidelines that are very weird
i'm curious if he's gonna play into them but
we'll see let's uh i mean i i heard something over
the last uh couple sentences you mentioned someone
by the name of hammer that's a pretty serious uh
bit of preparation that alexandra must have been
doing for this match oh yeah she doesn't remember
her lines hammer would be very disappointed
he was very he took his because this was some
preparation he had from a few years ago oh and
greg okay so so far greg has been playing
exactly into the line that hammer prepared
so it's very interesting yep so you know what guys
this is going to be one of our segments during the
commentary we're gonna go to uh andrea for the uh
botez opening phase analysis and she's gonna let
us know whether or not alexandra should have any
clue what's going on here and you're saying so far
this is actually something that she's
maybe prepared well okay knight b6 was um
is it's a stray from the books so now no more
hammer lines just fluffed alex but alex should
already have the advantage and there's
this e5 move right away from alexandria
i'll just describe it as well it may be a very
good move but i'll just say it's very committal
uh it gains a lot of space it pushes
black's pieces back but at the same time
one of the things you always have to be careful
of is white's king is in the middle and hasn't
castled yet is at least a few moves away greg with
the black pieces has already castled so anytime
you start advancing you worry about maybe getting
too overextended uh in the opening so that's the
only risk here for alexandra and she's already
taken on d6 yeah if oh i guess she couldn't
i i guess you could have defended it actually hmm
like knight f3 instead yeah yeah i was considering
knight f3 but now night on h3 now it's not always
a bad move but when you see a move like that you
know that the person who's playing with the white
piece is doing it intentionally because knight f3
was available but she said no i want the knight
on h3 she's clearly remembering something maybe
the hammer said one time and one call he's like
hey alexander put the knight on h3 it's good here
what do you think of that move so one idea was
that she didn't push h3 which was a main idea in
this position so that she could use that square
for a knight but that doesn't mean that it was
correct in this position i'm not sure i was
thinking maybe she's eyeing that two squares
so she doesn't have holes around her king but do
you think knight h3 was stronger than knight f3
uh i have to say with the open
e file i'm inclined to say no
and i was just highlighting this on the board
that the c pawn was actually hanging there
because of the pin and what alexander was probably
counting on was that after bishop takes g7 if
the king took back she actually has this great
queen d4 move hitting the knight in the king no
but i think i think after that oh my goodness
after queen d4 we've seen the first bow tez gambit
what a way to start off i would not be proud alex
amber would not be proud of this game i don't
know what i think she played way too quickly like
she played all these moves so fast and obviously
greg's tactical calculations a little bit better
but you know i think she just wanted to start
you know with an iconic botez gambit it was just
for content she didn't actually miss the tactics
definitely not uh this is not a scripted match
alexandra definitely just going for content here
and honestly andrea i just couldn't think of
a more a better way to start the match better
win yeah exactly and now she's going to win every
game now that you know she shows off her signature
and how the real play comes in yeah yeah and and
something tells me that uh like basically a bow
ties gambit at this point is almost like a 50 50
if it's going to happen honestly greg did not look
that surprised he was like okay yeah one of those
yeah well alex was flying back face falling so
that's very interesting okay well we're on to the
next game it is uh although it's one nothing in
the match don't forget that handicap that's a part
of this match because of the rating difference so
it's 15 to one right now greg has made the first
strides in closing that that 15 game uh gap and
right now greg is playing the roxy bind which is
characterized by this pawn structure right here
and from my experience with the moroxy bind
generally it's it's a really comfortable position
to play for white you have more space at
some point you can get this knight into
d5 and alexander is going to be playing with a
kind of cramped uh position with not a lot of
space is this a position that you think she should
be pretty familiar with though andre yeah so we
studied moroxybine because this was the opening
i was going to play i play the hypixel dragon but
actually greg already castling is not um the best
move for white because white can black can easily
attack on his queen side so i think greg it might
be um yeah it's about equal so i think he's giving
his advantage a little bit he was about to castle
king's side and leave his rooks on the queen side
exactly like it's a little more uh natural
i think for most chess players in general
to castle king's side greg here has castle queen
side which honestly looks a little strange maybe
to to most people watching because it's like it
looks like alexander's already got this attack on
on the queen side but look how many pieces have
been traded off already and all of a sudden greg
says oh hang on hang on it's my turn to attack
yeah trading off the bishops was very interesting
because you know now it's more likely to go into
the end game position unless he's going for it
for the king attack which looks a little bit scary
but normally this trade should be okay for black
yeah so it basically if the queens uh disappeared
from the board imagine that then i think alexandra
should be very happy she gets that nice night on
on c5 so because of that white uh greg in this
case should really look to keep the queens on and
go for the king yeah that is black's goal here to
try to trade queens and go into then game and i'll
just play a bad move for a second uh f5 just to
show what alexandra maybe is dreaming of she wants
a position where her knight can choose from these
beautiful dark squares and everything's locked
up over here there's no way to get to her king
i don't know if she's gonna get that i don't
think greg is gonna be so kind i don't think greg
that's what she wants um so how would you look
to to break through here alexandra is kind of
playing in a weird way she's going for that sturdy
formation almost like a fortress um how would you
try to break through here with uh with greg's
position with the white pieces well do you think
trading on g5 would be a good idea well it's an
interesting question first of all if uh alexander
took back with the h pawn then i would say maybe
yes good idea because we get to push that pawn up
the board this bishop on yep might get in there
with uh with f5 and most of all the h file would
be open so maybe uh maybe greg could use that so i
would say after this alexander would be looking to
take back with the f pawn she just pushed open up
the file and then be able to put that knight on e5
so i would say no this pawn keeping the knight out
of the e5 square that's exactly what what i think
is good about greg's position so i'd probably
be looking to keep it there maybe go like g3 so
that i always have a pawn on f4 and i was about to
mention okay bishop to g4 and start to use some of
those weakened light squares yeah alexandra that's
what i was gonna say the weak color complexes
i mean at least one benefit for alex is that all
her pawns are in black and she has a light scored
bishop which if she does get out of this mess
and trade could be to our advantage but white
is occupying the light squares which are all
weaknesses around the king yep very well said
um and this is exactly why these pawns on dark
squares and light square bishop that's exactly
what i mentioned earlier if this goes to an end
game i think alexandra is is favored immediately
so as soon as those queens disappear end game
you're happy to have the pawns uh the opposite
color of your bishop whereas these white pawns
here it's fixed on a light square it's the same
color as your bishop you get to an end game with
this guy he's going to be able to attack that pawn
and white's only being able to defend so that's
why i think greg is going to be focused on keeping
the queens on the board alexandra definitely
looking for an end game exactly here i think it's
a little bit hard for alex to play because white
has pretty obvious plan to attack but for her
there's not yet a clear plan what would you
think is the best plan for black here to defend
or attack yeah there's a there is kind of an idea
um which is maybe a little weird but you actually
want to maybe take the pawn on f4 with pawn
on g5 in order to give yourself the e5 square
so you sort of secure that square for the knight
by taking the pawn and that's why i was mentioning
the last turn g3 as a potential for white so that
that couldn't happen and now as a result queen a5
greg says you know what it's my time to strike i'm
going in the center with e5 powerful move if pawn
takes e5 well the d-pawn takes e5 he's trying
to take on d7 and if the f-bomb takes e5 he's
trying to take then on g5 this is a wild move from
greg uh do you think it caught alexander off guard
um yes but i don't know i'm not following the e
value but i don't know for the best idea i have a
question if if black takes on e5 and white takes
the knight could he play something like rook d8
yep like to pin the uh yeah trying to win the
bishop back definitely definitely the probably the
in this position i would say i don't think that
can be necessarily stopped trying to think of a
night maneuver that might help here um
always got to be watching when these queens
are facing each other some some kind of night
maneuver but no that that actually looks like
kind of a reasonable the computer doesn't like it
i think white's still better in that position but
using the pin there seems very reasonable f5 by
alexandra though hitting the bishop with tempo
once the bishop moves then she can start thinking
about taking those those pawns in the center but
right now be careful you take there you still lose
the knight to a tactic yes she could also try to
be blocking up the position maybe g4 do you think
it's better if she tries to escape the pressure
and leaving white's attack on her g5 pawn or
should she push and try to keep blocking yeah
that's the main issue here is that there's f takes
g5 which i think is a huge threat probably the
most dangerous thing in the position yeah white
taking on d6 is honestly not as scary as white
taking on g5 so um in this position even if you
take on f3 um this this is going to get open the
g file gets open so i think if the g file gets
open alexander might just get checkmated she's
down a minute let's not forget about that as
well um yeah this is a tough position already
i mean i i think it's clear that black doesn't
really have any way that she can defend the g5
pawn so i feel like moves like here she should
play quickly because g4 seems a little bit forced
yep yeah i think it is also uh a line of thought
where you maybe take on g5 let that happen let let
the white pieces take on h6 as well and then hide
your king uh but at this point i think alexandra
has to make some concessions she has to do some
[ __ ] yeah at least for so she's not wasting
too much time already down a whole minute yeah
and at this point she might consider a move that
doesn't look that great maybe e6 just to keep
things closed um taking on d6 though i think might
be the way to go and and then just put the knight
on on f6 afterwards yeah e6 and all we can say is
white's up a pawn and it's right there on d6 yeah
looking pretty strong it's a very uncomfortable
position that pass fawn is very strong and her
king is very exposed very hard to defend here
yep no at this point i think uh i think greg's
even got ideas like rook takes e6 uh like i
haven't calculated that one up fully but
i wouldn't be surprised if it was a half
decent move i think it's not necessary for greg
because he's up so much time he's up upon no need
to maybe go crazy unless you're sure there's
a win but just the idea of taking followed by
maybe like a queen check and queen down to e7 to
take that knight um maybe some checkmate ideas
this oh he didn't go for it i thought he was gonna
go for it i thought it looked pretty promising
but i guess he can just prepare it oh i like
what alexandra is doing she's playing quick
both of her last two moves were attacking moves
towards the king that's what you want to see but
it might be just be too little too late with 19
seconds yeah she's trying to create some sort
of counter play some attack on the king maybe
hoping he'll miss something in her time pressure
but i think now that she's let that deep on free
there has to be a forced win coming up pretty soon
yeah the thing is once you uh you don't sacrifice
on e6 the first time you're not about to do it
the second time right so i don't think greg is
really on that uh that sacrifice uh kind of idea
anymore and uh hang on i mean queen b6 b2 pawn
is always pressured here the knight does guard
the e6 pawn yeah she's just finding a way to
hold up hang on knight d3 something at least
signs of life here b2 is hit both
the rooks and the queen are a hit
so i think we're gonna see an exchange yeah
i don't think greg can save his exchange but
let's give credit to alexandra she she made
a game out of this for sure 1984 i think was
probably the move there not played and all of
a sudden alexandra flipping this game around
oh my goodness that is definitely what she is
best at under time pressure even a completely loss
and that's something she always tries to teach
me to find any attack and put as much pressure
and seem like it's working for her now he's in
time pressure yep and we've seen we have i think
we haven't seen dragon time pressure so let's go
alexandra i think thought she blundered but she
didn't yeah i don't know what she was reacting
to she thought she missed knight a4 forking the
rooks but she would have taken it with check
she thought she blundered that's the that's
well she's playing great right now andrea
i don't know she's got five seconds she's
gotta focus up now we're gonna see who's really
better in the end game except with this immense
pressure take that pawn oh rook f3 is a great
move as well but even if she sacrifices here
i think she's got it she's playing really really
well right now this is a great save she's found
now she has to be careful of knight a4 knight
c5 oh no what are these oh no alexander oh no
those two pawns are connected i spoke too
soon oh my goodness did we jinxer yeah we
may have oh man it was hard to spawn under time
pressure but yeah the knight c5 was brutal wow
she had such a nice save too yep but at least
you know she can it seems like greg obviously
a little bit sharper at tactics but seems like
she can play pretty equally in the end game
well it it has to be said that alexander basically
clawed her way back from yes a dead lost position
and that's already a really good sign for
the alexandra fans out there that if she if
she can do that she's she's not going to have
a hard time what is up with that move well what
is happening okay uh okay i don't know
what i'm uh seeing here yeah i don't
really know what's gonna think white's
still winning no that was the winning
incredible it was weird it was almost equal for
for a little bit oh and there goes the rook okay
well it was like you said i think this gives
us a lot of hope for the future matches
uh yeah sorry i'm just getting used to it
except for the very last few moves whoa okay
andrea a lot to a lot to take in there but uh good
things all around if you're team alexandra in that
yes um greg did show a few sides of weakness there
he's been very consistent but maybe a few things
that we finally noticed that he's not invincible
in these time scrambles and and alexandra really
did hang in there in a position that uh honestly i
might have given up sooner than she did she played
year yeah i was a fan of that i don't know if
greg was maybe getting too confident in the win
because he's normally seeing those type of tactics
and he had so many winning tactics there so we'll
see if maybe he'll be a little bit more careful
with his winning advantage yeah i think greg um
uh needed to to maybe go for that sacrifice you
remember that sacrifice that we were talking about
so maybe now that you know we're in a new game
he might reflect on that and feel like he needs
to play more aggressive in general yeah we'll see
if that changes in the match especially when he
has the win but yeah so i see we got into the
same position they got into in their first game
yeah and this knight b6 move you
mentioned like hey this is kind of a weird
you know off the book move but that's exactly
what good preparation is sometimes you know
your opponent is preparing against you and
you're saying look i'm not going to play the
best move in this position i'm not going to
play the most common move i'm going to play
a move that you've probably never seen before
because i know that you haven't prepared for it
yeah i think i think that yeah his correct idea
is e6 um and that was what alex had prepared
his knight b6 why it throws her off i
don't know how much i like it for black
because i feel like his knight doesn't really
have anywhere to go the c4 pawn is defended
he doesn't have a four square so i don't know
how good the b6 square is in general oh yep um i
think what we're seeing here is probably going to
look pretty weird to most people you know night h3
taking the double pawns it's like hey andrea when
you were learning chess didn't they tell you don't
put your knight on the side of the board yeah this
semi looks weird to me i don't know if this is a
an idea have you seen this before i'm on i'm
proud to say it happened okay so maybe it
isn't i was thinking like maybe i don't play this
opening maybe it's you know a unique sideline but
so one of the one of the reasons that i think
she's playing it is because i'm just going
to take a second and just go back because you
mentioned e6 for greg being sort of the main idea
then i can see knight h3 being the move and then
the knight goes to f2 guard c4 guards g4 but the
knight on h3 can't be taken when there's a
knight on d7 and pawn on e6 so i think that
alexandria had a plan going into this position
she got surprised by knight v6 and she's still
trying to follow her same plan but it doesn't work
as well against the move that greg had i agree but
you know hammer always says respect your bishop
so maybe it's not bad because black does sacrifice
their bishop here for that absolutely no this
is not a bad position by any stretch i mean as
you can see by the eval bar it it's hovering
quite close to to equal um i think that greg
is probably happy with his position but um you
know honestly compared to compared to the last
time they had this where alexander blendered her
whole queen yeah better exactly this is awesome
yeah sometimes the open jeep on the king you can
use it you can place your rook on it bring your
king to the corner and use it as a way to attack
your opponent's king so it's not always a weakness
but it is a little bit worse to play for white and
more uncomfortable yeah uh just just a positional
element that hey if we get down to an end game
it's pretty easy to play for for greg and greg
right now launching full pressure against this
f4 pawn but a bit of a counter-attacking move
here by alexandra hitting c7 hitting a7 and saying
look if you play c6 you're gonna lose your d-bomb
exactly and maybe coming to the d4 square later
and e6 is also a weakness yep yep and then a6 now
he's saying look you take my pawn where does your
knight go after he gets attacked actually stuck
behind enemy lines yep knight c7 then i distract
so maybe she's gonna utilize that d4 square
yep and if knight d4 i think greg would be very
interested in playing the move e5 uh hitting the
f4 pawn hitting the knight as well and if
alexandra takes that we get something that
alexandra wanted in the game where she was black
which is that beautiful knight sort of occupying
the yeah square yeah e5 is a pretty good rebuttal
so i would be interested in sort of going back
knight to uh c3 and then after e5 trying to play
f5 yeah and he sees it yeah initially i also like
you man we see we make the same mistakes alex
we're like yeah knight d4 night in the center
and then oh father's night coming to e5 and then
our bishop is gonna be under attack okay and this
is great andre it's really rare that the audience
gets to see like you know you're here as a as a
simulation of what the photos might do and then
we have alexandra to you know actually execute
the move there so that's a nice little insight
we have i mean i hope she's not playing the same
moves i'm getting because i'm lower rated than
her so hopefully she doesn't place every move
i suggest or maybe it's a good thing maybe
it means that i've made it up to her level
yeah and there's that move c5 uh which i think
is is pretty much going to be a knockout blow
um in my opinion here i don't see how alexandra
saves a piece knight and that um is necessary
defending the bishop um alexander played b3
in the previous position because her pawn was
being hit but just sort of overlooking the the
need to play bishop to g2 so it's these tactics
yep but i don't think she could have i mean even
if she would have defended her bishop i mean
probably still would have been but who knows she
came back in the last game from a losing position
she could do it again yeah and what's what's uh
funny is that although people might not realize it
this game she's maybe down a full piece but the
advantage that uh greg had last game might have
been as good as this or even better he wasn't
maybe up a full piece but he had such a good
position and you're absolutely right she she came
back then although it feels harder to do that when
you're actually down a full piece yeah i think the
peace advantage is going to be harder for greg to
to throw and the time let's not forget
a factor yeah two-minute advantage here
um basically the last time she used the
time against greg greg got low on time and
she used that to create some blunders but with
three minutes i don't think greg is gonna be
getting down to 20 seconds anytime soon yeah
especially it's very hard for her to find a
counter attack in this position last time you
know she had that potential idea of doubling on
the foul the king but here her king is so exposed
she doesn't have much time to attack yep and uh
well speaking of an attack there's a one move
attack you like to see it yep she's just trying
but unfortunately it can be easy easily blocked
yeah and that rook is looking to access the g-file
towards the king that knight is going towards
that e5 square and even if alexander takes that
pawn i was going to say it's not the end of the
world for greg because all he's looking to do
is trade trade trade when you're up material
just trade everything that's equal and then
what will be left well your extra material
so i think he's looking to just simplify here
yeah i think that shows just how much of like a
weakness like the double pawns and the the exposed
square in front of a king how big of a difference
it makes when you're playing someone rated like
2700 that that positional advantage will make
all the difference in the end of the game
absolutely yeah a small positional thing not even
down material just just the way the position looks
can sometimes be the difference yep king h1
uh was played i mean time is uh very low for
alexander here just 35 seconds um she is
uh keeping the idea of hey bishop takes h4
rook takes h4 and at least there's some queen
h8 tricks there so the greg is doing his last
double triple check he learned his lesson yeah
so i think he's just uh spending probably most
of his time on this move come up with a good
one solve his problems but um yeah alexander
is hoping for bishop takes on h4 and greg comes
up with queen e5 uh trying to force a trade
yeah even with her check the kings can easily
escaped escape and and black has much stronger
attack on the king yep yeah i think i think
trades are all that greg needs to go for here
um something like bishop takes now still met by
rook takes h4 let's not forget um alexandra's
king by the way is almost getting checkmated
as well yeah so it's kind of a race here
the viking has the f7 escape square but
white's king doesn't have anywhere to run
yep so i don't know one move if you're really
trying to trade everything would be like bishop
g5 as you can see it just like hits absolutely
everything in the position um if you really
want to just go for some trades you might
lose another pawn but you would at least
uh get the pieces off so we'll see yeah and he
can oh i was gonna ask why do you think bishop
p5 is better than trading bishops right away
yeah just the rook takes h4 just not not even
dealing with those queen h8 mates yeah i i feel
like it's not a huge threat but it's definitely
good to not give your opponent any counter play
yep and there's a really nice move by by greg
understanding that hey if bishop takes although
i just lost a piece queen e4 yep check me
yep he removed the the rook that was defending
the pawn and yep there you go that was a very nice
tactical play by greg played very well this game
yep and he's he's opened up a a uh a third win
here so three wins in a row for greg people might
be wondering hey why is the score you know 15 to
three i just got here alexandra is crushing this
guy uh the game or the match rather did start with
a 15 point handicap which the players agreed on
and as i've mentioned before it was actually like
oh i think we should do a 12 point handicap
and greg was like nah make it 15. 15 sounds
good so that's why the score is currently
15. confident with this handicap and so
far he's proving his confidence correct but
still so many points to catch up for greg
yeah and if you just joined you missed uh the
second game andrea we would agree maybe that what
that was the best chance for for alexandra um this
match could easily be two to one right now yep
all right all it takes is all it takes is like
you know one or two wins uh in this uh in this
five minute portion to keep that you know 15 point
lead kind of uh reasonable going into the bullet
exactly and then who knows maybe she'll have
some better chances in the bullet and let's talk
a little bit about this uh this game we got here
alexandra going for the french which is an opening
that she's quite uh familiar with is this uh again
something that maybe you could speak about her uh
her opinion this is the one i refuse to memorize
because i'm not a fan of the french she loves the
french so this was the one that i told the hammer
alex is going to study all on her own so i don't
know well from what i noticed with her french
games is that her opening gets a little bit messy
but maybe she maybe she did um review a little bit
of her french line so yeah alex you're on your own
the french yeah if people uh you know watch uh
alex and andrea's stream you'll probably know
already that alexander plays their french all the
time the franchise to her like the london is to me
perfect there you go everyone has their
opening that um you know it might not be
the the most popular or maybe it is but it's
dear to them and they you know they won't
speaking of french positions it could be worse
that's the way i i like to talk about the french
it's like you know whatever you got it could be
worse always remember that so i think that's fine
here i think your position is actually pretty good
here yep this knight e7 move definitely looks like
something intentional she's done uh it would be
more natural to have that knight on f6 but then
what would happen with the open e file is that
knight would always be able to jump into f5 yeah
using the pin so that's a really important detail
that she put the knight there covering f5 and
also blocking the e file so um i like that from
alexander knight on e7 yeah i was gonna say the
position looks pretty comfortable for black after
she could castle she has a strong dark diagonal
her development is pretty equal so it seems pretty
even to me yep one thing that um has to be said
although i do like the move knight e7 is that when
you castle kingside now there's no knight on f6 to
sort of save you when things get messy all of
a sudden queen e4 makes a checkmate threat that
could be very hard true that is true actually
yeah queen e4 is fantastic idea i didn't even
think about i guess the only way to defend that
would be like a knight g6 move yeah knight g6 or
some of those ugly looking pawn moves that you're
never sure yeah weaknesses yep and alexandra is
she's playing rook c8 she's playing knight c4 so
i'm a big fan of what she's doing she's playing on
the side of the board where she sort of has
the space is a little bit stronger over there
but one thing that i'm looking for is when is
she going to feel confident castling because
at some point she's going to have to castle and
it's all about to me how she handles the king
side pressure once she puts the king there with
no knight on f6 yeah i was going to say i think
she she was aware of the same idea you were
talking about so she was delaying her castle
as much as she could trying to build up an attack
on the queen side but it may be time eventually
she's gonna have to castle she can't leave her
kingdom forever yeah you and your opponent kind
of look at each other and it's like well are
you going to castle yet you know yeah exactly
i always have respect for them when
they're they're delaying their castle
yep so i guess one of the only other things i
would consider is the move e5 if you want to
delay your castling that's one of the ways to do
it one of the issues is right now if if you start
collecting the knights and you know alexander
takes back you would drop that e pawn although you
get the bishop pair you would drop upon doing that
and you're not really advised to push pawns in the
middle of the board when your king is still there
so yeah and when the queen and the girl attacking
on the same file it doesn't look too safe yeah so
in that position in the position we just saw and
maybe in this one as well i really think that
it's probably you know a decent move to castle
but i agree but alexander just i can tell that
she's a little bit scared to do that which is fair
and the longer she waits though the less likely
it is that she's gonna castle yeah i i feel like
she i it must be the queen e4 threat that she's
scared of but i don't know it looks like black
could pretty easily defend with 96 and maybe
try to attack the queen on the e4 square but
she has a night maneuver plan bring your knights
in the center okay yep and i think alexander might
be interested in giving up the bishops here just
yesterday the queens and then once the queens are
treated it's like all right sweet i can castle
exactly i'm curious if she'll go for the end game
yeah the other the other options remember if you
want to try to like kick that knight out with f6
i mean your king's still in the middle
you're running into queen h5 and
that's almost a knockout blow right there so
nice okay i like that she went for the sun
game and as we saw from one other game she can
play pretty well in these end game positions
yeah finally i think she's pretty happy
about that yes i think this is a relief
so maybe knight c6 um so basically here
we have a position with time even i think
alexandra has done the right thing definitely
i would call this a success for the opening
knight c6 she's going for trades uh i have to
point out that with the two bishops and the the
pawn majority which just means that there's more
pawns on the queen side for white on this half of
the board i would prefer greg's position and
i think he's going to be happy with it but
alexandra can't complain about what she's
got from the opening yeah he does have the
bishop for advantage but her night on d5 is
very strong so i'm just compensating for it
yep and i'm also going to say that rook on e5
looking a little weird like it is that bishop
is blocking its way yes for sure and now exactly
now it can't even return anywhere cut off from
the e file but white is definitely eyeing that
f3 square and i was going to say speaking of f3
i don't know i don't think the pawn
push was a did you like the f3 pawn push
i i thought that's a square i i definitely
agree that it looks weird i think it could have
been punished by alexandra because she played
really quickly she immediately played rookie
and i think she might have missed an opportunity
there because f3 is a move that you really want to
play it shuts that bishop down completely and then
i don't have six it takes away all the squares it
wants to go to so in general it's a really really
good move but the in the position that greg played
it in his rook was still on this weird square and
i feel like alexandra had a moment just a brief
moment there to take advantage of it i don't think
she did so in the end i think f3 paid off for greg
but yeah um it didn't have to it didn't have to i
think she had it how could have black punished it
so the first thing that comes to mind if i'm just
going back here for a sec is uh knight d7 uh just
to again hit that rook yeah forcing it maybe to e3
yep forcing it to e3 which is another weird square
then maybe the knight jumps into like c5 into b3
where it hits the a pawn it's a sort of a long
yeah now the dark squared bishop can't really
go anywhere so that this makes sense okay
i guess it still has the e1 plan but yep so that
i think there was a moment there where something
could have happened but let's get back to the game
time even a minute for a piece literally dead even
and alexander's king is more active she's finally
going to kick that rook out it looks like and she
does and uh again i think uh most people will find
it a little funny that greg's bishops developed
and then he said uh actually put those right
back where they keep yeah exactly they're both
on the back ring and she's starting to take
up older squares and they don't have the dark
square bishop doesn't have many places to develop
anymore yeah and pro tip for anyone chat watching
if you ever want to look like a grand master just
put your pieces back on the squares they started
if you ever put your pieces back on the squares
they started during the game everyone's going
to assume that you know exactly what you're doing
exactly that's really good because it seems like
such a beginner mistake but no it's just cause
it's too high level for us yeah do you have a
lot to understand yeah if anyone calls you out on
it you just tell them like ah it's just too high
this is a grand master thing just can't explain to
you why it's good but it is yeah exactly exactly
so pro tip there um rook d8 again alexandra is
keeping the time even and keeping the position
relatively even but let's not forget those bishops
are just creeping around they're starting to act
yeah they're finally trying to get out
of their shell i'm looking at the move c4
um i think that you know unless there's some crazy
knight f4 like tactical type of move hitting both
bishops or something if that knight goes back to
e7 then i think the bishop just goes to c3 or b4
and i'm really starting to like the way those
bishops are coming alive yeah c4 is very strong
it looks at first like it it was a weak move
because you know the pawns are so advanced they're
not defended but i agree after that bishop plan oh
look greg guy's gm he's doing it again every time
that happens we just we can't question it guys
yeah he he tends to play a little bit passive
when he has some really good aggressive plans so i
don't know if greg is more of a passive player but
well check the time as well alexandra is doing
really really well on the clock this is the part
i was most interested to see to see if she could
play in the end game at um the 2700 level and hold
the position and so far i'm very impressed and
she is gonna have games where unfortunately she
just gets kind of crushed tactically that's gonna
happen against a strong player um and we know it's
going to happen but in the games where she gets to
these positions yeah end game stuff like this time
even she's got to capitalize these are her chances
i agree maybe okay i was going to say maybe bishop
e6 looking for a trade but she's just kind of
dancing around and i don't want this from her i
don't want her good strat she just makes safe safe
moves goes back and forth just to keep her time
advantage yep then that is totally fine totally
fine keep that d file it looks like yep yeah
yep they certainly are okay and she needs to play
f5 or h5 here has to be one of those two moves yep
so they don't lock her bishop back okay she goes
with f5 takes takes i don't mind this for her
g6 and she may have an isolated pawn but her
bishop is defending everything so the bishop's
going to go to e2 and h5 wants to happen if
she did h5 that wouldn't be the worst thing
bishop e5 oh oh this is bad news in my opinion
greg is really starting to activate those bishops
c4 she's doing well on the clock
yeah i guess the bishop in the center just cannot
be attacked because it doesn't necessarily do
anything but it's just gonna it's such a strong
square controlling almost both of the biggest
diagonals move that pawn play h4 h3 that's what
i've done i don't mind this from her though she's
going aggressive she's gone oh no oh he has three
seconds though everything anything can happen here
yep that's totally true totally true there's only
plus one let's not forget so trading rooks oh wow
it's funny alexandra's display picture
on chess.com almost looks like yeah yeah
exactly i was going to say i thought that was
a live look at alexandra i didn't even notice
that yeah that's how we started the match man
that was so close i never really yeah i guess
that check kind of threw her off and took her last
second andrea we are gonna go to our basically our
halftime break right here and if there's someone
who maybe needs a half-time break refresh right
now i think it might be alexandra so she's
gonna go run down and give her a pep talk
do that in fact do that i i think we would i'd
love to hear about that afterwards so yeah we're
not five minutes i might go dude dude you got
this proud you're getting these winning positions
yeah well she's still winning technically
in the points so yeah exactly she's still
waiting guys let's not get 15 to four
so we're gonna take a very short break
when we come back the rest of the
five plus one portion be right back
all right and hello everybody welcome back
hopefully nobody went anywhere that was a a
break for us in the commentary booth here for
the players as well so they got a little break
um and uh andre any any uh you know behind
the scenes insights into the bowtie's house
yeah well alex came running up asking me for
one of my hats and i think that's like greg's
reaction i think he liked alex's hat she wanted
to snap back but i said that she should match
greg's hat so let's see if the hat brings the
wins oh and an energy drink she's really um
oh and a blazer okay she wants to win the the
outfit award now i like it very classy look
looks like a little british lady well yeah i
was gonna say she went from like uh you know
alexander botez chess player to alexander
botez you know uh covert spy yeah exactly
some sort of uh one of those type of movies i like
it though she's going for a shift she says look
it did go that well before when it changed
everything the outfit the hat energy drink
i'm going uh way way different anything you
can do to keep your mentality positive and
looking up for the next rounds and uh one
thing that's important to note for the audience
and for us to remember as well is that the match
clock for the entire match was paused during that
break so it's not like it was any advantage to
either player uh the the clock was paused and it
will simply resume right now when the matches
resume so no time lost there in the break
all right and we're back in d4 by alexandra that
the the d4 is probably going to be seen you know
time and time again that's yeah openings and she's
also i don't know if she did uh had any time for
some chess review maybe uh talking to hammer
on the side there but we got this line again
yes oh i'm curious if well is this the same line
oh no it is yeah i'm guessing he's going to go
again with the knight b6 he probably is because
it's been working for him yeah i think normally
when you're having these type of um we call them
theoretical discussions with your opponent i think
what you normally do is if it's working for you
you just close your eyes keep doing the exact
same thing and say hey look you got to do the
work here it's fine for me i'll do this all day
yeah well and on white side hopefully
she's learning from her mistakes like
that [ __ ] that knight h3 move that
wasn't good she can try different
different plans okay speaking of a different
plan uh this one does look different she tried e5
um there was a knight h3 try and now she's
going for queen d2 so we'll see if this uh
pays off here but i think she's really conscious
that the knight on f3 allows the move knight g4
i don't think she likes that which is why she's
not putting a knight on h3 so i think this knight
b6 move by greg totally throwing off alexandra
and as we can see here opening trouble already
yeah this is a very aggressive move which
gets rid of the knight g4 threat but
uh interesting we're gonna have to give the
alexandra's b3 was there no way to save it
well at this point i think because the pawns
being attacked like you almost have to play
bishop takes knight on b6 which is an ugly move
um that would save it but it's not a move that
you're really supposed to play in these openings
which is why alexandra didn't do it um but she's
she's not solving the the knight b6 move by greg
and i think that is highly effective for him yeah
yeah she needs to find an idea but you know
there's luckily with the speeches we have so many
games she'll have plenty of tries and hopefully
i have time we get down to the quicker matches
we'll figure out a good line as white and that
the the worry is that when you get to shorter
time controls it's even worse yeah position like
you know because it compounds how bad it is so
what alexandra needs to do and it's very difficult
for anyone but for chess players it's difficult to
adjust on the fly she has to basically the next
time she gets the white pieces she can't repeat
this she has to somehow think in her head
what went wrong and what can i do that that
would fix that and she has to do that while she's
thinking about all the other games she's playing
not easy to do exactly yeah that's the whole point
of why we're preparing our opening so much so so
that she doesn't waste time in the opening because
obviously giving um greg a time and advantage is
gonna be even more of a blow yep and what we see
here greg is just taking a pawn he's saying look
queen trades fantastic winning pawns fantastic
he's just looking to trade down here he knows
he has the advantage early on i think he's gonna
snap the queens off yep and take that knight back
yep he's using his material advantage but i
mean yes he has a weak isolated pawn could maybe
get a little bit of material back yeah
alexandra is going to have to i was going
to say show off the bishops and andrea i mean
what's going on here where's the bishop c1
and looking like a grand master that's why that
move i think your bishops are pretty active and
this position i don't think that but i know
hammer hammer would be happy with your bishop
there we may be down some material but at least
you know our bishops are very active yeah oh
they're active all right there's well the the good
thing for alexandra is she's lost all her pawns
so there's lots of space for those fishes to
be active exactly let's look at it that way um
yeah looking looking like this should be as i
mentioned alexandra is going to have games where
unfortunately she gets into trouble uh gets beat
tactically uh greg is a stronger player he's gonna
have a few games where uh let's say it alexander
is gonna get crushed a few games but that's okay
that's part of the match she has that handicap for
a reason and she needs to capitalize on the other
opportunities that she gets it's crazy that he's
finding all these tactics straight in the opening
which we were preparing the opening exactly to
avoid that issue but he's finding these tactics
in the positions we didn't study so yeah and i
think and i think it's very safe another one this
is almost resignable yeah three and a half and
she is going to resign i i totally agree with that
it's a full extra piece just get to that next
game no point in dragging that one on back to
the french that was i think her best opening i
agree it went well with her it went well for her
the other game and going into strong end game
so so i would say that she just needs to repeat
what she did last time she uh was doing
well on the clock doing well in the position
there's no reason to change what she did uh greg
is repeating his position uh when alexandra is
white so i think she's yes that's what i was gonna
say yeah greg has his repetition for white let's
see if greg which how he will change his response
to her french yeah i wonder if if he is because if
there's one thing i know about you know ims gm's
when they get those positions with the two bishops
they feel like they're supposed to be better
so he might actually repeat it as well
go right back into it just it's kind of like that
stubborn you know strong player tendency like oh i
have to be better you know let me prove it again i
mean he didn't he wasn't getting in a bad position
in one equal position so i guess there's no need
for him to change it necessarily yeah and and uh
you know if both players are happy getting back
to the same position we might see that but already
something completely different i think was it
actually alex that was knight c6 played last time
uh this really i can't remember yeah cause
i i know she went with that knight a5 plan
but i don't remember if white was able to
trade yeah i almost i don't know the french
yeah she definitely did okay yeah she waited
to move that night much later in the game
interesting interesting so maybe that did
happen last time and greg didn't trade
can't remember at the moment but uh all that
needs to be said is that the current position
is different than last time it's totally
different the trade has put the queen on c6
normally what black ends up doing is at some
point going for like b5 bishop b7 uh putting that
bishop on the long diagonal and saying hey that
knight can't move or you're gonna get mated on g2
so do you think the trade is favoring black
now in this game yeah i think uh i think in
this line where the queen goes back to d7 in this
french and you go b5 bishop b7 it's nice to have
the queen on c6 because i agree you know even if
the knight goes to d4 to hit it once that bishop
gets to b7 that's no longer an option so um again
though with h6 i think what alexandra is doing now
and maybe a little bit concerned for her
is i feel like she's kind of combining her
ideas from the last position into this position
and they don't they don't transfer that easily
yeah exactly i think she needed to go straight
for that developing plan h3h6 wasn't necessary
yeah um because without a knight on d4
there isn't as much of a risk of knight f5
and what i think is going to happen here and i
was about to say it is just like i was gonna say
yeah that that trade looked too juicy to do
that to the pond oh and there's the pin okay
yeah oh not another tactic man puzzle rush
instead uh so that's the is that the botes
flaw for this match to too much opening
theory not enough tactics i yesterday when
we're training i was like i also thought we
were spending too much time on the opening but
because alex and i you know we play way more games
and we do like real training on stream and puzzles
so we definitely need to work on our puzzles
yep and and shout out to chess.com they have
a puzzle week coming up because that would
be perfect that would be perfect no the
chess.com puzzles are great they're very fun to
practice so yeah well tell that to alexandra yeah
that's true i think this one honestly is uh
resignable yeah just like the last one this
is a full rook and it's going to be a full rook
plus the bishop is going to escape after you
don't even get the bishop for the rook yeah it
seems like she's walking into these tactics with
a move like h6 instead of going
straight for the development plan
i'm trying to find like how she keeps walking
into these opening puzzles what is the common
factor um so one thing that i could maybe point
out which i have mentioned in the other line is
i feel like greg is doing uh he's doing a kind
of tricky job of playing a move that maybe isn't
the best but it just gets alex that little bit
out of her preparation and what she might be
familiar with and then what what alex does is she
plays the way that she intended to play initially
against the the new move that greg does it doesn't
work the same way and greg is really taking
advantage of that that's what it looks like to me
yeah that makes sense because that knight takes
c6 move was definitely favoring black but clearly
that was the whole reason we fell into this pin so
yeah yep and greg immediately went b3 bishop b2
in this game why do i mention that because that
bishop hits that g7 pawn and that's exactly
what alexandra's knight e7 move doesn't cover
so it feels like he's he sees what moves she's
trying to do what what different ways she's trying
to play um and he's yeah he's covering it exactly
the way the way it should be i'm very curious how
should she have defended the g7 square because
her move knight f6 seemed i don't think that
if six was the mistake was it no probably not
forced it's probably just b5 that gave the game
yeah yeah but also it's the order in which
you do things remember if she had done
um if she had done b5 before maybe bishop d5 would
be possible it worked true that would have helped
and let's also remember h6 if the bishop's going
to b2 a move like h6 probably not necessary at
all you don't even need to play h6 so maybe you
get that knight to f6 first no h6 then you have
time for b5 and it's just that game of chess
is often determined by just those few tempi
in the opening exactly especially at this level
it's just one move in the opening that doesn't
necessarily push back your opponent's bishop or
develop the knight before the pawn and they'll
make all the difference yep and knight h4 just
again looking to solve problems tactically here
alexandra's king is in the middle of the board
and she cannot really take this this bishop on b7
um i like the fact that she's playing one of these
games out i don't think she should just resign all
of them immediately um at least make greg prove
it a little bit but with the amount of time he has
and the rating that he has i think he's
got it yeah it's probably resignable soon
just because i have faith that greg with this
material advantage i think that uh basically
she's playing on because that bishop's on b7
and yeah look it once he saves it you know i'll
resign then he's up a full rook but i have like
you know just a little bit of a few more tries
yeah exactly let's see i mean okay the bishop's
hanging here so that's yeah just take that and
i think she might resign here once she realizes
that you know one more check one more check one
and knight takes f5 here is going to be
lights out after king eight yep all right
oh no i guess the rook hanging is also
there oh no she threw that she's
getting rid of the figure she's throwing
that's actually op she's tying her hair up greg
can't copy that's how you know it's getting
serious she always says she thinks better when
she puts on her ponytail and greg can't match
that so maybe we just know that this is dangerous
yep andrea this is dangerous i think alexandra
just took the opportunity no response she finally
took him out of the books okay well that is the
first time we've actually seen alexandra uh come
up with you know uh some opening moves maybe off
the board that greg couldn't handle oh i'm excited
for this so this is a line that hammer prepared
and he's walking into it perfectly so this is a
line we and we're originally not gonna go for this
because it gets us into a really weird position
so i also have to think what was the line here
i believe we we take and now we play queen f3 we
have prepared i'm really excited and then takes
him takes to a position where black could force a
draw and if they don't it should be giving white
slide advantage and greg being the stronger player
he wouldn't want to force the draw so exciting and
alexandra playing e4 wow that's uh i've always
known her as a d4 player so if she's playing e4
better believe that she is trying to play against
something very specific she's taking her time here
but i know i know for a fact we prepared queen f3
oh wait no no no alex we prepared this together
how did you forget this one even i remembered
this one oh no this is this is where you gotta
this is like wwe wrestling you gotta you gotta
tag you in for that move queen f3 and then let
her play the rest we'll never forgive the he found
the most beautiful line he was so proud because
it was greg's pet lion and greg would play the
same response every time and we forget queen f3
i'm very upset i i don't know any anyone watching
just don't show this to hammer just make sure
you never say oh this didn't happen camera's
currently doing a commentary but he said that
after he finishes he's going to go look and uh
alex you better remember and this was the first
line he taught us and now alexandra is probably
like uh you know i don't think this is now she
doesn't know how to play it and i i think black's
already winning oh man that queen of three
boobs i'm so upset yeah i know especially when
she's not she never plays these positions so
it almost looks like after an a5 i don't know if
this is a thing but queen d4 and then if knight
c6 you play queen takes bishop and if bishop c6 i
think this knight actually just gets trapped like
it's so weird but there's no place to put it yeah
black definitely has a big advantage here and he's
played exactly that which is not a good sign and
we don't we did but that was another thing like if
greg deviates if we deviate then it's not going
to end well for us because we never play this
and greg does uh andre i think this is maybe
the third game in a row now where uh honestly
alexandra's kind of been lost in about 10 moves
it's not it's just the opening which is it's so
rough and it's definitely hard for your mentality
because it's not like she's too weak of a player
he knows these lines so well and he sees these
tactics but when she gets into equal positions
we've seen that she has a really great chances
so you just have to remember hammer's lines alex
oh man this this is where uh it's so difficult
because if if she could just check that line
for like two seconds in between the games it
would be so helpful but you cannot do that
you can only do that during the breaks yes
of course yeah that's why i like when i be
preparing my tournaments like right before
rounds you finish your game you have like
30 minutes before you you do a quick recap and
that can save you so much energy during the game
yep and honestly what we're about to see
here alexandra is going to lose this night
and literally she will have no peace development
yeah it's it's pretty much over from here i think
maybe bishop there is an option but unnecessary
i think he's just gonna take that back
maybe she did need me after all castles and now
i think well bishop bishop to g4 is definitely
an option uh it might look funny here that greg
basically has his entire queenside pawns wiped out
by alexandra's night just hopping around taking
everything it is a piece down it is a piece down
yeah and i think i think at this point um you
know hey if alexandra gets all of these pawns
sort of up the board she definitely has chances
but she's so far away from that at the moment i
mean yeah if those phones were advanced they would
be killer all past pawns you know maybe she can
pull something off yeah hang on andrea let's let's
you never know more connected past pawns hello
i know those are stronger than maybe even two
rooks yep they can definitely be uh stronger
than a lot of pieces but generally what where
they have to be is closer to your opponent's
side of the board yeah they haven't made a lot of
progress but you know one day one day they'll get
there yeah alexander just needs about 10 moves
for free and then we might have a game here
rookie 8 played and there we go all right
we got one of them up there they're coming
yeah the troops are are marching
in yeah and look how scared he is
he's doing he's doing those gm things where he
puts his pieces on the back row yeah i actually
i lost him i hope because i was so deceived by
the eval bar which for a computer like it looks
like a huge advantage for white but i don't know
i don't think it's as over as i thought it was
i think what's the issue is again queen
c7 it's like almost impossible to me
wow queen c7 g3 loses the h3 pawn and it's
actually kind of the same position if you
remember when alexandra was playing the french
i was talking about queen e4 it's kind of the
same problem it's so hard to defend that sometimes
yeah wow and well i guess what could she even try
unfortunately i'm kind of out of ideas here
she almost has to play something like f4 like
kind of yucky move but if she pushed h4 and
then queen c7 and then g3 wouldn't that save
the i mean the bishop would still come to h3
but then rookie one you don't lose that pawn
that's true what i'm concerned about
in that position is bishop g4 to
f3 and then like queen into h3 and
meet on those weak light squares but
oh no but it wasn't good so this wasn't a
good sign yeah sometimes you're happy to
see the coffee moves sometimes it's uh yeah
i mean anything was losing but what you know
greg didn't play did you guys play the you you
said bishop g4 right he did e3 he he wants to
end this game a lot quicker he alexandre literally
has no pieces developed yeah she can't even take
greg is looking for a ko here yeah bishop can't
take and then rug takes it oh okay well there
we're going to get fourth but you know alexander
is going to lose this game with not a single
piece leaving the back rank yeah it's pretty crazy
because like the position without that mate threat
would have been totally playable for white but
this one attack that was so unstoppable was the
whole was the whole win well i think she's doing
i think she's collecting pawns at this point yeah
yeah if queen takes bishop by the way
there would have been rook check and
she would have lost her bishop
and this is looking pretty over
if i was greg i would try to style on her and
play queen takes f4 queen takes f4 wow pawn
takes bishop takes and then there's a rookie
one made idea so i i would look to style here
you know it's not that great but as you can see
the eval bar black's still winning after sacking
the whole queen on f4 yeah i i think greg needs
to give you some um fashion points you can put
on some hats and you need to give them some
style points in the game perfect i'll take it
a nice trailer that is that was brutal but it was
just that queen of queen ups3 line that we missed
and uh andrea what's happening here as greg
has now won seven in a row is we have to
start talking about a few things number one
is that after we need seven games we realize
he might win almost the most games that have
ever been won in the five plus one portion
because the games are so quick that's the
problem is that she's losing them so quickly
um that he's actually able to get more and more
games in so he's scoring a lot of points and
the other thing we have to talk about is she's
dangerously close to losing 10 games in a row
yeah but you know maybe we are also approaching
the other time formats and the but the issue is
if we don't solve our opening issues then alex
doesn't have any advantage in the shorter time
formats yeah it's like you know any any alex
supporters coaches out there if you're listening
she needs a good pep talk after this uh five plus
one portion about a few of those openings because
it's just the openings but yeah once she gets past
the openings we've seen time and time again she's
had fantastic games where she actually is really
good in time scrambles a lot better in the end
game portion and greg is kind of as you pointed
out a little bit passive uh decisive but he hasn't
been forced to play any of those positions because
he's winning the games because he's getting these
so killing tactics in the beginning but you
know he only has like half of her points so
still out of hope yep and uh let's let's be
clear alexandra in this position it might
not have been so great last time but this was
her game where she actually could have won yeah
the the issue with the moroxy bind also she never
plays the sicilian this was my opening and i had
memorized these lines because i love playing
against the roxy bind but uh we're messing up
some of the ideas here and we should be punishing
his queenside castle because it's incorrect but
instead he's getting the attack on our king
so yeah and king's or queenside castle rather
screams to me like it's one of those moves uh
that it might not be the best but again it's
not an alexandra's uh yeah opening theory and
it's just taking her out of book just enough
i mean she's trying she's she's sacrificing
something trying to maybe open up nearest
king yeah you can't you can't lose pawns
if you sacrifice them first yep exactly
you know last game she had too many funds and now
we're sacrificing them she has to find the balance
exactly somewhere in the middle we'll get there
we'll get there just gotta keep experimenting
yep yep okay so a4 a3 and this
has been seen before by greg
he pretty much always stops uh the a pawn
with a3 and he's gonna eventually like
shuffle his king over to b1 maybe even right
now uh knight d5 looks very strong to me oh no
yeah this also looks strong he's going for the
attack usually the idea after knight takes h5
hey we all might be tempted by these rook sacks
but another idea is to get that queen out to h6
and go for g4 um yeah open the h file that's why
typically i always try to push h5 and because if
you allow whitetail open up exactly once they
bring their queen it's so hard to defend and
all right now i think that queen age six
that i don't even know how but could defend
yeah i think greg was like look queen h6 after
i take with check king f7 i don't really have a
checkmate right off the bat and he wanted to get
his king away from some potential pins make sure
so he's saying look i have that for next move now
it's your turn again because it's unstoppable so
good to stop while your opponent's counter
play first yep that's a definitely a very
very mature decision there knight d5 is also now
possible again because he shuffled the king over
so that would threaten 97 and the queen and the
queen would uh for white would also come into h6
as we talked about so this is looking pretty good
for for greg and i know there's plus one seconds
but you look at the time he's only used like 30
seconds wow yeah he's just killing it straight
from opening but you have to say while he was
playing a little bit he's a little bit more of
a passive player that shows off as one of his
strengths because for me i probably would have
just been really distracted by the queen of six
went to the attack but his preventive moves are
a very good skill yeah and and at some points as
you pointed out maybe in the end game later on
you know he needs to be more decisive but the
fact that he's playing these defensive moves
even when he's in an attacking position it works
really well exactly he learned his lesson where
she gave he rate gave alex one attack in one
of the first few games and never did it again
yep 100 and hey rook c3 might not be the winning
move the best move but i i kind of like it she's
trying something you know when all lost is all
hope is lost you got to try to create some issues
yup i do not hate this at all um after let's say
king b2 has an idea to defend the pawns the rook
might go to b8 for another sack on b5 and after
queen takes uh h7 king f7 i don't know you know
we're running away yeah it'll be it'll take
him a little bit of time to look for a defense
yeah so one one i guess attacking idea after
queen h7 king f7 might be rook h6 to keep in
mind hitting that g6 pawn and you know maybe five
but just that that is probably how white is going
to look to proceed yeah so white's attack is too
forcing and it doesn't give black time to bring
the rook to g5 and yeah but as as with attacks
hey the computer might be like uh hey craig don't
worry it's plus four yeah good question but at the
same time a human looks at this and says yeah it's
intimidating and look at that oh and he's playing
that there we go like we said that passive play
he sometimes it's good but sometimes it's blocking
his sight from seeing the winning forcing attack
yeah absolutely i mean alexandra gets maybe
the rook over this bishop can slide into
b3 and as soon as this knight really joins
the game like knight e6 knight f4 knight c5
and once that knight gets in there i
think there's real chances for alexandra
but she has to play a little bit quicker right
now and activate all the pieces yes exactly and
it is giving a little bit of hope that he's
he's getting scared he's getting defensive
but the time like you mentioned two minutes
already yep um i think rook v8 is very reasonable
rook d4 and what is he planning here something
that i think is really annoying he's maybe
planning to take that pawn but maybe more
importantly he's gonna stick that real quick
guard the pawn and be like look yeah that
everything's protected now what are you gonna do
yup he found a good defense of course you
know he sacrificed a bit of the attack but
now there's no chances for black to enter the
king yeah and and we might say hey greg should
have played a more aggressive move than that
but if he's gonna play passive the problem is
he's really good at it he's a really good
defender and alex's strength is definitely
like finding a comeback and he's losing
positions and he just never allows it
i think rook b4 is the way to go here yep look
before and there's no more attacks on his pawns
yeah she can take that but she
would be walking directly into a pin
herself um either c4 or queen b2
would take care of the threat there
now i think there's still hope basically
if alex can get her knight to c5 that'd be
fantastic unfortunately now knight e6 is met by
bishop c4 and queen g2 would be a protest gambit
let's not play that yeah it's hard here because
in time pressure when so many natural moves are
losing and you have to waste time calculating here
there's just it's so much pressure to keep up with
17 seconds yeah yeah and the other thing is that
greg knows that she has low time so he's going
to play like kind of tricky moves he's going to
use that against her he's definitely putting the
pressure on okay c4 at this point the knight to
me just needs to move the knight needs to like
i like that yeah i don't know i mean he does
have a pass pawn but putting all his pawns on
the square of his bishop kind of locked it in
and now she can finally develop her own bishop
i kind of like i i like the plan she's making
for developing her pieces still still winning for
white but it's improving yep completely agree the
knight is finding uh a path to a good square here
c5 d4 f4 depending on what she wants to do but
i think that's great yeah there we go you can
see the computer starting to understand like
white's got a great position but hey black's
position is kind of improving a bit yes but the
issue is i think those two past pawns are just
might be unstoppable yep alexander's doing a
good job getting the king off that diagonal
you never know when there's going to be a
chat king on a dark square nice and safe
he's trying to go into the end game
makes sense but those four sets material
nervous here the time 4.3 remember you don't
get like plus 10 seconds every move you get
plus one one which is hardly anything it takes
most people one second to process the move
or think of the next one yeah honestly that
the time is the biggest exciting factor and
i'm almost flagged there yeah yeah she almost
has to be in like pre-moved territory exactly
oh my gosh wow yeah it's crazy because like
once you get down to two seconds you're never
going up you're never gonna get to
like a equal 4 second every round
so some kind of quicker tactics there um i
like the speed from alexandra i can't say
i'm a fan of the moves but she you know she
just doesn't want a flag but it's lost yeah
all right here we go and i think we'll get well
you know let's let's hope for alexandra's sake she
doesn't lose the game in 10 moves but i think
this is gonna be the last game in a five plus
one time control i don't know whether to be
excited or worried about the other time controls
but maybe the fact that greg will have less time
even though he'll have better opening positions
maybe her speed will give an advantage and he
won't see him killing lines i absolutely agree
with that both ways yeah the lower the time the
better for alexander and look for the first time
she finally admits the london she admits that
her younger sister has the better opening
yes i i dude if i was there i'm telling you um but
it's okay i i always get very picky when i watch
your london because london is the only player
only opening actually has white which you know
i'm gonna branch out soon but i i've studied
a lot of those lines i'm a big fan of london
so how's she doing right now um so well the
knight normally doesn't come to d2 especially
pushing c4 knight c3 is better but hammer did
discuss that he doesn't like the doubled c
pawn so i also i respect your decision so pretty
solid so far maybe not my my line but i think it's
so far so good well if it's not your line then
it must be garbage yeah exactly uh knight d7
so black wants to play e5 generally in these
positions i am not a fan of playing bishop on
d3 because i never liked the the idea that could
end up on e4 so i would go for like bishop e2
and bishop h2 yes that is my line as well yeah and
i agree knight c3 might be sort of a little more
following my instincts but knight d2 the way
it happened trey queen's out can't complain
about that it's more that alexandra needs to be
familiar with bishop ii bishop h2 ideas and she's
got [ __ ] yeah my only worry about the queen on
d2 is that if he gets e4 the knight doesn't have
the d2 square but now he'll have he'll have the
d4 square so right um now in the london just as a
general thing uh there's not many positions where
i get attacked on f4 and i go forwards to g5 yeah
it's definitely not theory but i think
for players like greg probably doesn't
have all his lines against london
memorized so it might benefit her
yep i think at this point the bishop is not
going to get trapped it can always you know
go back here so no worries about that i think
castling is pretty important for white to do and
just as a general thing couple moves ago i'm not
a big fan of taking on e5 i think yeah yeah comes
back with the bishop that you know she can keep
her center pawns and be happy about that but uh
position is not bad here uh i think she just needs
to play a little bit faster have more confidence
in this london yeah i wasn't a fan of it either
but i would say maybe it was good because then
because her knight doesn't have the d2 square at
least trading would mean that her knight could
go forward once they push e4 and now she's got 34
push so just getting into an interesting position
so she might want to go with bishop h6 to trade
pieces off it's kind of a lot different than a
london now it basically feels like a king's indian
yeah this bishop also might want to go back to e3
and first off greg says look you just played
e4 your pieces don't look like they can do
a good job defending it right now how
do you handle a simple one move attack
with a simple one move defense makes sense yep
this looks good i like that a bishop is
controlling the d8 square so she can bring
her rook to the file but and normally the f6 move
i normally don't mind it because it you know it
blocks his bishop it opens up the light square
diagonal so i wish i won g5 i was doing a good job
yep yep and it probably should come back to e3
it hits the knight from that square so if it ever
gets attacked i think that's where it should
go um i'm wondering if greg is thinking about
something very aggressive sort of in the f5 realm
but it looks like no he's he's going positional
f5 is always very difficult to play i wonder if
well you could still go for it eventually yep
queen on c6 um basically greg is playing on the
dark squares here and wow kind of combining all
the ideas that we mentioned f5 is pretty strong so
f4 is the one you don't want to overlook that is
a free bishop so careful about that and if you
take on f5 um first of all i don't think you
can grab this pawn on g2 because there is
bishop f3 but she is going to go f3 to get
bishops did you think f3 is better than trading
on f5 and pawn takes back on f5 well yeah the
thing about taking on f5 is that it doesn't solve
your problem you're still facing um f4 uh true
so if you're going to play pawn takes f5 you
better have the next move ready so i don't
mind this for alexandra i don't yeah i at first i
was skeptical but then i didn't realize yeah the
f4 thread is unstoppable so mine is well blocked
yep yeah knight b3 so she's covering this i think
i was gonna say he's gonna play a5 and look to
kick that knight away question time for alexandra
is she gonna play a4 and she does i think that she
gives up a lot of squares but i like the move yep
what did she have to play there i'll just point
it out because i think it was kind of important
instead of castling after bish buffet
i think she would have punished greg
if she had maybe played c5 herself yeah i think
she she played so quickly there because you know
she saw bishop before giving a check she didn't
want to waste time but you know this is a very
interesting move it's harder to find it's not as
intuitional so this this position i'll just say
is so rough for white just because of the fact
that we're sort of headed towards an end game
and there's going to be the two remaining bishops
are going to be these ones yep and the bomb and
guys in chat can we get a count on how many light
square pawns alexandra has because yeah it's going
to be rough in an end game i think greg is up on
time he's got a great positional edge and i think
from what you and i have seen from greg's play
so far he would love this kind of game yeah and
you know he doesn't have to take it now but the
issue is the bishop's pin so it's bound to happen
yeah and to some people this type of advantage for
black is like almost better than like a free pawn
uh just just having that dark square control
everywhere um and if the pieces just trade on the
d file the bishops trade if everything trade trade
trade for trade it's going to be even material
but alexander is going to be pretty far
behind probably more than than you might think
yeah i wonder if she could try like king f1 hope
hope he doesn't take the bishop and then maybe
put that guy somewhere but i don't think there's
any way to avoid oh maybe greg heard you yeah no i
don't think greg would miss the the bishop trade
yep um i think he think he's gonna oh that is a
okay i think that's a weird move you didn't like
his pawn takes i mean it connects it brings like
you know a backwards pawn but it does connect
his pawns then again the e5 pawn is in weakness
so i don't know if he needs the defense yeah so
i think that alexander can try to set something
up where like the rook goes on d3 kind of guards
her weak pawn and she puts her queen behind it
like nice and then she's hitting a5 she's hitting
d6 uh she can put her bishop on d1 to guard that
uh pawn on b3 i don't think it's the end of the
world for alexandria i think she needs and she's
done exactly that big fan of what she just did
yeah pretty solid fortress here i don't really
know how black can enter breakthrough maybe
yeah maybe h5 g4 but oh so an easy thing to
underestimate is that uh trading the queens is not
actually a good thing for you um as white because
now black probably uh you know over time will
be able to get that king to c5 to b4 and if the
queens are on the board that can cannot take those
kind of journeys that makes sense that's a very
good point see i'm actually i always like this
commentary because i learned a few things as well
my mind games are my weakest parts so that's a
great endgame lesson because i never really know
when you want to trade the queens and positions
like this yeah and it's kind of tough because you
feel like hey black has the upper hand and he does
yeah you want to trade the queens to get rid of
the pressure yeah exactly the queen for white was
probably the only thing keeping her really in the
game there wow so this is a position where greg
is basically gonna waltz his king sort of around
to lisa yep he's doing exactly that and he's
going to play h5 and g4 and alexandra is going to
she could watch him as well maybe like over to the
queen side yeah what do you think about that she's
doing it yep so what's going to happen here is uh
she's going to be successful in getting over there
but after black plays h5 brings the rook over to
88 and plays g4 black's going to be infiltrating i
see yeah if she could have maybe defended the file
so that he couldn't come to the second rank but
yeah her rook is dropped in by that bishop yep and
he's he's got the g5 he's gonna play g4 once he
gets g4 he's either gonna go like g3 or pawn takes
and he's to infiltrate and he's going to be first
and being first is all that matters just one move
behind for her i know it's it's painful because
the pawns are even here the pieces are even it's
like hey i should be like losing this it's crazy
it's like almost exact dead equal position but
just one move behind will make all the difference
yep um so i think a little bit of a strange
move greg played rook g7 instead of just playing
yeah he seemed to waste the tempo yeah 100 i
don't think that was necessary very important
yeah i don't think that was necessary um still
he's probably comfortable happy here um but
alexander can't complain she's got a rook down
there as well yeah and i like your bishop there
a lot seems to be now defending and the rook
can't enter anymore especially now that she has
the file yep absolutely um and hey if greg like
puts his bishop somewhere like and it gets traded
it's actually checkmate on c8 so you gotta be
super careful it's starting to look like a draw
to me i'm not sure if greg can break it anymore
yeah probably what um he's hoping to do is get the
bishop to g4 so in this position if greg moves his
bishop alexander is going to have to move i don't
think she wants them oh and she's going to be in
sioux wrong soon because she's going to have to
move a rook which is going to allow bishop g4 yep
and what she has to do is whenever this is a move
or threatened she has to be threatening check me
somewhere on this king yeah and if she delays and
moves her king back then he would be able to come
to before but okay he's alexander is doing a good
job so if if the king starts to move back i would
instinctively move my king towards the king side
interesting yeah and then the only way i have
the king side is because couldn't black try
to come king c5 king b4 yeah so basically
as many squares as black is away from c5 i
would be that many squares away from c3 okay ah
that makes sense and what just happened there
greg just did a sort of a classic trick where uh
he just shuffled he just shuffled the piece he's
gonna win this game now he got the tempo
and that was not losing for alexandra but
he he just waited around and unfortunately
she did make that mistake in time pressure
um yeah this is completely lost here it's
so hard because she could have held the draw
but it's just those her last seconds is under
10 seconds he had a minute yep it's not easy
i'm just gonna go i think the position's
weird i'm just gonna go back to that yeah
after king c6 it's like what should she do
just move her king she had the rook covering g4
king back king d2 king anywhere really she's
covering it i'm gonna get back to the game just to
watch the end here but that's exactly the
moment where greg didn't have a threat but
it's like she thought he had a threat so she made
a different move so the rook should have only came
to the back rank when you played king c5 when
it would only actually have a mate threat right
you've got it oh you've got it
a nice little end game lesson
that's so rough because she was so close like so
close came back from a disadvantaged position and
almost had that draw yeah and you saw the look
that you kind of the handshake that that greg gave
there at the end he knows that he probably knew
that that wasn't totally winning and he didn't
have a way to win it but he was just kind of
going in the grand master shuffle the grand master
shuffle uh well we'll call it that i like the name
the grand master shuffle well this is that i'm
not a gm tournament so uh greg is already you
know if he's playing like a gm he's he's over
performing for sure i always call him a gm
because we were talking about those gm moves
with the bishops and he plays like one so you know
exactly exactly so alexandra is uh uh started with
15 points greg won nine games in a row uh there is
not gonna be ten games in a row in five minutes so
hey no no adoption and five minute portion we can
we can say that that's the goal here we go no i'm
excited for the next few games i predict alex is
gonna have a nice comeback yeah and uh the next
portion is gonna be three plus one so that's why
we think you know alexander has been doing well
in these time scrambles uh that when the game goes
longer she does a lot better you know she's gotta
get out of those opening troubles the break is
gonna be good for you know the chat to get their
snacks refreshed for you and i to take a short
break and for the players especially to refresh
before coming back so andrea we're going to take a
short break here and when we come back we're going
to continue with alexander botez against greg
shahadi in the i'm not a gm tournament after this
and welcome back guys you will uh only
hear my voice for now but just wanted to
uh introduce you guys to and remind everyone of
the arena kings season six which is uh getting
started monday january 11th so uh 20 000 prize
fund for that i think that is one of the kind
of most well-known events uh andrea on chess.com
and we get another season of that um has uh has
alex been been competing in those uh you at all
i think i did playing arena kings i remember like
uh two years ago alex i'm not sure you'd have to
ask her but i know these are always a lot of fun
to watch these are also my favorite yeah it's
like a full season competing for prizes starts
monday january 11th and pretty much all your
favorite streamers should be or will be competing
so just a reminder about that i know that's also
a reminder for me to pencil that in the calendar
all right and i see we're back
here we got the cams what is greg
he actually does do crossfit i remember i learned
that about him when we first played our match
he almost looks like uh he's just pacing in
his office he looks concerned i don't know you
know they sure have been working out before
these rounds keeping themselves energized
alex needs to pull back her dumbbell yeah what
happened like she started the match full of energy
lifting weights then she changed outfits drinking
energy drinks like what's the game plan for
three minute time control she went from the the
healthy athlete to the normal chest streamer the
the caffeinated drinks then you know yep i see
that she's made the full transition now yes
their final stage our real form yes exactly uh
three minutes plus one second increment that
is the new time control um it's it's all the
same it's 15 to nine so that 15 point handicap
coming in handy because uh honestly it'll probably
be very close going into the bullet if the current
pace that greg is uh on keeps up i want to see
alex hustle some some blip games now is the time
yeah i i think uh one thing that has to be said is
any time you have these uh match-ups where maybe
one person's kind of the the stronger player going
in all it takes is one game one draw one win just
get on the board as alexandra and the confidence
just goes through the room exactly she just needs
one breakthrough yep for sure i've seen so many
matches myself where like i'm leading and then
my opponent gets one win and then just like that
they're starting three four five games in a row
yep love the move e5 here from from greg i think
it's exactly uh what needed to happen uh b7 is
yeah it's possible to take but rook d1 also it
seems like her strat now is to just go back to
her her most comfortable openings i see so nothing
that's been prepared so maybe that greg won't have
anything against this but e5 was a great e5 is a
good move now one thing about three minute chess
just to talk about the difference in the time
controls uh one thing that changes well obviously
there's less time but what that means is that you
can't really uh spend you know a minute thinking
about a move because that's a third of your
time all of a sudden yes you can't you can't be
doing that so uh a time advantage in three-minute
chess is gonna be a lot more significant than in
five-minute chess but the other thing it means is
that your time runs out a lot quicker so the hope
for alexandra and the way that she's probably
approaching this is hey let me try to play a
little bit quicker get greg down on time uh and
not you know just survive the opening and things
are going to go a lot better as i say survive the
opening i'm concerned for her here yeah speaking
of time advantage and i do the same mistake it's
so sad to see 40 seconds on one move and i know
exactly how it is because i'll spend like minutes
on one movement blitz you just get so caught up
you think you're losing yep so there are a few
good options there for greg bishop g5 looks very
very sturdy because i mean how do you stop this
very simple tactic removing the defender on f6
yeah i i think rook v8 missed this then just a
little bit too defensive from alexandra she needed
to say look you know forget that pawn i'm already
up upon from e5 just castle you know yeah exactly
yep yep this i mean she's down a minute here and
it's just these opening issues for alexandra um
the games where she sort of gets out of the
opening no problem it might even be worth it
for her to spend a little extra time in the
opening make sure these things don't happen
be down on time in the middle game
but at least be in the middle of you
yeah i have to say underestimated greg's openings
i didn't think she'd be finding killer lines every
single game it's very impressive yeah it
really is it's not easy uh no matter what
your readings are you know sometimes i'll play
a i'll play a 1500 and they'll get to the middle
game it doesn't matter right yeah exactly
this is uh an impressive impressive showing
by uh by greg here and that is going to
be taken on d7 with the rook i imagine
yep but you know she can just practice her
speed here when we're down well more than
an exchange but an exchange was a generous way
to put it yeah yeah uh an exchange of a queen
as soon as she gets a good opening i know i know
she can turn the tables but this game isn't it
that hurts okay it's all
right just shake it off and
new opening new game new try she needs to keep
her head up yeah yeah well uh greg is actually
getting one point per game and alexandra is
losing one point per game so she's just entered
the 2099 territory so greg is slowly feasting
on her elo one point at a time one point for
game well yeah but then again if she wins
one there'll be a lot more juicy points
andrea did she look at the line tell me she looked
at the line okay look i don't know she hasn't been
up here i don't think she prepared okay queen f3
yes finally all right so i believe here the move
is h wait is h6 just give alexandra the point
right now yes okay correct 94 correct beautiful
everything nice nice nice nice okay she's
doing it she remembered finally remember to lie
are we still doing it i i'm going to um uh okay i
don't know if queen of state was correct um is it
not gonna lie my memory didn't go that far
okay oh it is wow this is all theory yup yup
this is correct he could have played the
line that we prepared was bishop e7 here
we take on e5 oh no no i think this is still
correct nevermind sorry yeah queen is queen takes
now and then bishop e7 and then queen b8 check
and if they block that would be the drawing line
but something's going astray but white is white
has the advantage so clearly the line worked
in your favor and greg must have went out of the
books giving her the advantage wow this is a this
is some deep deep finally for hammer hammer would
be proud this is what hammer's been waiting for
and this is what we need to take hammer is
sitting somewhere in a rocking chair with coffee
yes you know the smile is just forming on his face
very satisfied now this is hard because she's up
so this is exactly hammer was like telling us you
know you're you're up how much of are we here um
i mean material points but we have a very weird
position actually yeah like two bishops for black
he's running out of ponds but alexandra has almost
all our pawns but no development yeah that's the
issue so we have a big material advantage it's
obviously it's much better for white even though
something must have went wrong but the hard part
is the lack of development yep and i i'm not sure
what like how black's supposed to play this
but um keep in mind there's a pin on this rook
so yeah i know wasn't correct so yeah no this
this move looks very reasonable from alexandra i
think she needs to play d3 knight e4 like bishop
out and just like long cast yeah quicker start
developing yeah and luckily that's it's a pretty
easy plan for white it's harder for black so
yeah i wonder if he should bring the knight back
in like knight c6 knight d4 if b4 needs to be
played to hit the knight uh i mean the computer
is certainly favoring white here but i would say
this is the kind of position that could go either
way still because it just looks like a total mess
oh queen check winning the pond oh but no the rook
e6 but yep no you you don't want to take this pawn
but i would say you probably want to give that
check and then i don't know like almost like d3
i want to say is there any problem with that yeah
bishop h is not quite a threat but what you might
consider is rook takes g2 rook takes g2 bishop
h6 i don't know if that's like a working idea but
it certainly looks tempting to me ooh i like it i
think now it's time for alex to show some tactics
all right could could you oh well your idea
wouldn't work right because the queen could
just defend the bishop yeah the queen could just
defend the bishop um i think it's reasonable to
still like maybe go for it and play the end game
after that because she is up some pawns so that's
an option the other option is get the bishop out
and just like try to castle yeah especially when
she's well she's actually up on time but in these
short time formats i think she should just go for
the more comfortable developing moves that takes
less time to calculate she does so good yeah this
is it this is gonna be it don't throw alex this is
our game okay knight's being hit now if knight e4
bishop takes e4 and if you take on g6 bishop takes
g6 be careful bishop takes e4 is a winning tactic
bishop c5 now okay takes there is mate
what has to happen i believe it's knight e7
and the only thing i would say to be careful of
for alexandra is rook h6 somehow like trying to
get the queen but right now she's got queen takes
e5 and it would be met by rook takes rook e6
so just bishop or sorry rook h6 be super careful
that queen i think it's lost after rook h6 rook h6
i feel like there has to be something i mean she
could also just sack if she really needs to take
the rook in the bishop yep well you were saying
lost for for white or for black so you're saying
for what yeah it'd be lost for like rook age six
the queen would be stuck on each eight if you
took the pawn then okay so yeah i lost for white
yep just because of her her material advantage
exactly even rook h6 she could just treat
big fan big fan over here nice move alexandra
this is it knight is coming in finally we're
the ones starting to take the queen yep but
greg's not going to go down that easy f6 uh
if rook g8 though there's still knight f6
okay alexandra actually think
this one check and just exchange
she's thinking she's looking for something better
i i think knight f6 is totally yeah i just got it
she's already up so much material 27 seconds each
i think she made the right decision there yep
what's it gonna be she gonna trade i queen h1
let's keep in mind that's the idea queen h1 check
i mean she could she could just castle and be
safe i like this move though yep i like this move
i think trade i think greg might take the rook
on an a1 no no okay so she's going to give check
and castle maybe and queen takes eight too oh she
didn't trust me too let's go alexandra okay she's
she's being bold checked i like it though because
she's not scared of anything and his time is
sticking yep rook b1 good good i like all of the
defense queen f5 queen yeah she can defend here
this is it though she's got to get this game yes
it was all the opening line yep can't take because
then we get check on b7 very nice he's playing
super well here b3 almost looks like a mouse slip
i don't know what that is but i think he wanted
to keep the c file closed do you want me maybe
nice job by alexandra he's absolutely yep
just careful here alexandra but you know
you've got this carefully associated f7
don't play that that's the botest gambit
not that one okay king's nice and safe maybe
rook a2 rook a2 yeah okay two very nice i like
it i guess yeah comes a6 so i would do queen c6
just trade the queens you know you're gonna win
true true just the queens she's played so well
though yes the eye is one second uh-oh let's go
oh very quickly nice finally i told you it's the
shorter time control just she's celebrating like
she just won the match that's how good it is
she's so happy because it's her first i mean
yeah after 10 losses in a row and a lot in a
long time control it's been a while an hour
of just defeat so this is a very important win and
let's let's give alexandra the the full credit she
deserves because that was a nice that was a
great game nice preparation she remembered it
andrea and looking at the second try and that yep
that was the hammer line and you see what happens
when you listen to hammer exactly exactly and
hey we're back to this french line right after
which i thought has been going decent for her so
this could be good back-to-back uh momentum yes
she and now she won't fall for that
tactic twice if he takes on c6 so
yeah beanie on monkey w yeah yeah greg's got
the beanie uh-oh uh-oh so what happened last
time i think it was knight c6 here
by alexandria and then it was taken
she should still play because i eh the tank wasn't
bad for her there we go this is the same thing
yep this looks uh very very reasonable she
wants to this time i think take back with the
bishop instead she didn't have a good time with
her queen there yeah even though we liked the idea
now i think alexander needs to adjust though
her her setup has been like bishop out 97
and like h6 and i think i mentioned
last time when when i see b3
i'm not sure that i like go for the exact yeah
exactly which what would you even suggest because
it's not very easy to defend the g7 i mean i guess
knight f6 same thing yeah i think like knight f6
uh bishop e7 or maybe even bishop on d6 um is
totally fine but knight f6 against the bishop on
b2 looks very reasonable to me you don't need h6
as much you know yeah oh she still goes 97 yeah i
like the knight f6 a little bit better i wonder if
there was no i don't think there was any sack yeah
i don't think she liked knight f5 and in general
like that's the reason you play knight e7 oh yeah
what it's going to come down to is i think greg's
just going to put his bishop on b2 his bishop is
going to go back to d3 uh at some point if it gets
hit he's still pushing h6 and let's not forget
andrea she's going to have the same issue to
deal with are you comfortable castling that's all
hey she thinks there we go she did it perfect now
this is good no more threats all i can say is uh
from what i've seen so far from alexandra's chest
i think she went into the break and she looked at
a few lines and it seems to be paying off so far
yeah i think this is a good start i think so too
because at the end of the day we are i'm
cheering for a competitive match i want
things to be decided in the bullet and
if yeah like that it looked like it was
going to be a blowout so alexander
getting on the board there is huge
for the match and with her 15 point handicap
it is now 16 to 10. so it's it's heating up
a4 okay stopping b5 there um greg did and if you
play bishop like i guess like bishop to c6 or if
you move that bishop off the e6 pawn better
believe greg is thinking about a sacrifice
something or other which is hard so like black
in this position how are you even supposed to
improve that and if you can't even move your
your bishop that's already very defensive and
isn't this allowing well 1966 i think is is
pretty fair uh yeah no knight c6 is actually
okay i still think the bishop on b2 is gonna be
really strong like for example i don't know knight
takes knight followed by queen g4 just as an
example make a threat against the pawn on g7 how
do you defend that whether you're playing e5 as a
sample line like knight takes bishop takes queen
g4 let's say you play like e5 white sacrifices on
d6 black takes back and i can just see something
bad i was gonna say i don't even know if you
could take with the bishop because i thought maybe
the sack would work but he didn't take anyway
he started with queen g4 and i don't know now i
have a beautiful move yeah 95 and taking off her
his bishop pair might yep 95 definitely looks uh
like that's why i wanted to take the knight
first right on c6 and then go queen g4
yeah and knight c6 i think she had to take maybe
with the queen or the pawn which is much weaker
but now i think she has the advantage totally
agree 95 i think greg just sort of forgot
for a second you can see by the camera he's a
little flustered oh i love greg's expressions
i like watching a very you know
highly emotional chest yeah exactly
greg like just guys are really so passionate that
you can see the reaction it's always it's always
even better when the cam is just their entire face
because they're so zoomed into the game yep yep 95
so he's gonna just have to admit that uh yeah
bishop's gonna be taken and nice but we still
have to be careful though because that bishop on
b2 and that queen is still a very strong player
absolutely absolutely now unfortunately for greg
he had to move the queen off the g file you would
have loved to cast nowhere to go though yeah
now that she has a bishop pair she can control
all the important squares the g3 square
the g4 square nowhere for the queen to go
yeah after e5 it's interesting um i guess
knight f5 is sort of the the natural move
um yeah it's opened up her bishop air might not be
lasting very long i think knight f3 there's also a
big case for that move um and he might even prefer
it uh just considering he's also more passive
yep it keeps a little bit more pieces on the board
yeah and he does go for that f6 uh good move by
alexandra the move she had to play to defend e5
and greg i figured he's hoping to get in there
yeah but that bishop i i think 9 of 5 would have
been better trying to force her to trade one
of her bishops because then totally agree yeah
she's sorry f5 is the move now like that's what
greg wants to play winning now uh queen f7 was not
it oh wow it's it's that botez blind spot you know
yeah you don't see knight h6 man that's a killer
but uh 30 seconds wow she really had this game
too but both players are playing really
well right now yeah given the position but
unfortunately the position that we're given is
probably one that is winning for greg yeah yep
uh probably a flag oh she gets the move off but
greg's gonna have no problem taking that rub
basically going for mate oh
yeah she can't even take back
no okay yeah this is just designable
bishop d4 here yep she's still going
yeah it's a few more checks it's the tactics it's
the tactics now that that game was really good for
alexandra and well i think what we noticed is what
i'm noticing is the time is just like disappearing
these guys are in time pressure like in the middle
game yeah they're both thinking a lot they're
both thinking a lot yeah for alex that makes her
miss a few more tactics and then for greg maybe
he plays a little bit more passively than the the
aggressive move that could give him the advantage
yep okay so new opening and i was waiting for this
i was waiting for this she doesn't play e4 so yeah
what's gonna happen this is a a very very
clear uh flaw in the plan yeah it's okay she's
transposed to d4 hey whoa greg just blundered
big time wait a minute bishop takes f7 hello
oh my god somebody notices because oh my goodness
oh no this is basically nobody even knows
i i just have to point that come on alexandria oh
my goodness i need to be fair as a not e4 player
you probably see those you're probably seen those
patterns a lot but for me i didn't even spot it
in the first few seconds either yeah it's uh
something to always be on the lookout for when
you see an early bishop g4 and your bishop's on c4
it's like just give it a double check every time
yep wow that would have been nice if she would
have seen that but i'm surprised like greg fell
for it that's what i'm saying that's what's really
weird about that is that greg is like hey you're
not an ep player and then he blends a tactic
in three moves maybe he doesn't play e5 either
maybe they both don't know their lines here
that's possible and i think that's might even
be the case but greg probably said look if we
both don't know what we're doing i'm probably
better off yep exactly let's see if that
holds true so alexandra's got the bishops here
but uh her bishops need uh they need some taken
care of here and queen d1 big fan of that move
what happens after knight c5 bishop e3
yeah maybe bishop e3 d4 yeah i was going
to say is a very unfortunately very likely uh
tactic to fall into is there any way out here
i don't think so you almost have to go like
this is brutal yeah this this looks pretty rough
this looks a little bit rough here yeah she
just needed a safe move like bishop c2 and
and even with hammers no i i guess you're trying
to be tricky you know trying to pin the knight but
on on this time control i don't know how
much time she has for tricks especially
when greg is better at tactics and greg
just did the equivalent of a mic drop he
took the beanie and just dropped it on the ground
yeah it was like giving us a show here this is
wearing uh is he wearing like an i don't know like
an alice in wonderland tablecloth like what what's
his neck there it's quite the fashion statement
from uh greg it's a little colored shirt
um but you know what i'm gonna say is
the hard part when you're playing against
someone so much higher rated like 2700 you
expect that they don't miss any tactics so
i just feel like it's safe for like you know avoid
going for tricky moves like bishop e3 and just
play safe a nice bishop c2 because they will see
it faster than we do yeah that's a good point um
now i don't know if this is a good or a bad thing
but there is a uh there's a lot of people playing
guess the move on chess.com and i see someone
rated 400 who's guessed almost all the moves and
that's a good sign 400 maybe they just never
either they're not rated 400 or some people in
this game are rated 400. yeah one of the two is
one of the two wait where is this guess the moves
in chess.com in live chess yeah oh i see you can
play guess the move follow along in live chats
cool yep rook d8 and that's just a full
extra piece also a full extra minute
for greg here yep not our game but doesn't look
like it but she's still in it and i totally
agree with that given that it's it's shorter
time control more likely to have some blunders
botez has got to somewhere rating back as well
you know back over 2100 yeah true see we were
talking about those one by one by one point
but hey one win look at us we're back at 21 13.
exactly yeah it's all about the rating at the end
exactly queen d5 looking for trades that's exactly
what you want to do when you're up material
and conversely that's exactly what you want to do
when you're down material don't trade avoid the
yeah i like queen g4 she's looking to
maybe double the rooks get pawn to b5
kick that knight a little bit yeah
down a piece but if she could just
put him a little if she could
catch up a little bit on time oh
that's a strong strong idea uh
to just play each five i think
rook to c1 had to happen for alexandria there
yeah oh oh maybe she was trying to go for no
time to check she doesn't have a draw though
because she doesn't have a draw i mean she's
doing this on purpose losing the rook yeah i don't
think it's gonna work but it's a fun try yeah i
mean when you're already already lost might as
well try with something a little bit more tricky
like if greg had if greg had maybe
20 seconds here yeah but um you're
you've got some chances but with greg
got a minute and 20 seconds exactly
i don't trust it as much yeah time really makes
all the difference though yep and we look at
that uh game or match clock rather there's
you know 20 minutes left ticking down in the
uh three plus one portion right now so uh you
know the time for still a bunch more games yes
yeah unfortunately that full rook down is is
hurting here although one thing that's kind of
funny in chess is it's actually really hard to win
a game without a pawn without really hard to win
without without if greg loses these two pawns he
could be up a rook but it's just really hard to
win without pawns yeah i guess like if you ever
defend your king then you know you don't give
them any mates threat but they would eventually
just find some tactics and win more material
yep but it can be it can be very difficult you
you underestimate in this position that like
if black doesn't have those
pawns it's not so easy yeah
very true but unfortunately i don't think
he's gonna be losing either all right yep yes
that's good enough there well now oh yeah and
unfortunately she's never going to get to play
that e4 that attack that hammer prepared again
because i is going to be playing d5 against e4
yep absolutely rook to rook to g6 and uh
basically in this position i think that
uh he's gonna take that bishop alexander was down
on time anyway the score right now is 16 to 12 and
we are coming up to our little halftime break here
andrea people get a refresh but although the last
refresh we had i was like okay alexandra needs
this but in this case do you think maybe greg is
kind of happy i still think the bullet portion she
will pull it off i have a lot of hope and you know
the issue here is still tactics but if she
adjusts to this and instead of going for tricks
play a little bit safer could still you know
she started with a win one win to two losses
isn't too bad so i'm still staying very hopeful
yep absolutely well 16 to 12 is your score line
given that 15 point handicap that alexandra
started with and we're gonna take like i said
our halftime break so don't go anywhere we're
back with the rest of the three minute portion
and then andrea's favorite the bullet happens
after that we'll be right back after the break
so
and welcome back everybody to apparently our very
covet conscious uh scream andrea yeah i don't know
if this is gonna make them play better because
you know it's harder to breathe and sometimes you
get a little bit sweaty playing chess your heart
starts speeding up but you know i respect it where
we're supporting taking health precautions yep and
and alexandra is the front runner there she's got
she's got the the mask on there fully approved and
greg is wow he's matching it you know i'm curious
i'm curious how long they're gonna keep these
masks on yeah actually that's that's a fun idea
uh andrea how long do you think alexandra keeps
that mask on i'm gonna say okay if she loses i
think she'll take it off so the first game she
loses it comes off yes okay and i i will say that
with um 18 minutes left in this uh in this three
minute 18 19 minutes left in the three-minute
segment i will say that the mask comes off um
before 12 minutes left okay all right let's
see whenever that is let's see who's right well
they hopped straight into the games they're eager
um there we go yeah greg has got the uh quick
castle and actually alexandra is basically playing
like a hippo i i like what she's
doing because she remembers that
he's he was winning these fiance positions
by breaking through her king so now with h5
she's not even giving him a chance to start
pushing h4g4 well he can but not as as a girl so
we get a position where these extremely talented
players have all played a5 h4 h5 and andrea's like
yeah i love what she's doing i i know it looks
very counter-intuitive you know you're taught
pawns in the center develop knights and bishops
before you push side pawns but sometimes you know
especially of course when you're playing three
minutes you're uh you might go a little bit astray
from the opening basics but they might pay off yep
no that's certainly the case that in three minutes
and then uh even more so in one minute chess that
all a lot of the principles that you might follow
you know poof out the window a lot of the time
yeah of course very relatable like just stacking
a piece just to make them think you know
and i'm sure we'll be seeing some of those
but so how do you think do you think this is
going to pay off for alex trying this h5 a5 um
i'll be honest no no i don't think the other side
i'll say cupcakes perfect we have a good bet going
on yeah we might as well start gambling
just kidding just kidding we don't get it
no none of that no just in video games yeah just
video games and masks on everybody good stuff yes
um they've still got the mask on they do yeah
greg is looking a lot more somehow comfortable
in his than out yeah i know alex looks like
it looks like she's about to go into a medical
center or something so serious yeah very serious
greg's looked like you know the one that you might
wear exactly like he's going to the mall he's
picking up some some things looking fashionable
in his cute mask alex is here to uh murder
yeah and for the win and uh with knight before
in knight takes d3 i think alexandra should be
happy with yeah just happened i'm definitely a fan
of it i mean hammer is a fan of it and luckily i
always like this when things are getting locked
up in the center and you can castle safely it's
giving a lot of time to finally have time to
attack his king's side and one thing that uh greg
i don't think we'll almost ever do in this game
is play the move e5 but i wanted to point it out
that's something that alexandra is like dying to
see she really wants to encourage e5 so her knight
could jump to the f5 square exactly although
sometimes e5 can be really annoying because
it's gonna be hard to develop your dark squared
bishop and it's completely trapped in so at
some point it might come in handy but there are
bishop maneuvers on the f8 square and other ideas
yep and i think alexandra is probably looking to
launch like b5 b4 and meanwhile greg is looking to
play g4 which is why he just brought the queen e
yeah and unfortunately the i don't think there's
a piece she can bring to defend it um no uh one
thing i don't know if it's is uh good enough but
one thing is that after b5 before the knight is
actually trapped at the moment yeah i was going to
say an interesting idea maybe was like queen d6 so
g4 push f6 and the knight can't take and then she
always has bishop e8 if she needs to defend yeah
bishop on e8 is actually a very cool resource it
guards all those important light squares from from
the back row yeah i don't like her time though i'm
not happy about this 30 seconds and she's fixing
her hair on her time no no no this is not how we
take care of our time right okay now i'm gonna be
careful here she traded those double bonds which
may have been better to keep the position closed
and placed slowly when she's down a minute but
yeah basically okay not sure about bishop d2 um
i definitely disagree with that i think he should
have taken the bishop and just moved the knight
off the last yeah now her bishop is the monster
now it might actually pay off that she opened
it up yep and if if greg ever plays e5 it will
hit the bishop and block it but it gives
away those squares we've been talking about
i think she has a great position but
with 14 seconds and one second increment
she has to be has to be pre-moving almost
everything it's still the middle game and
she has almost 10 seconds yep the you might say
oh alex has this game she just has to play fast
but that is so hard to do she can start trying
some safe pre-moves but they'll just get punished
man this is three speed yeah and actually just
start preventing some trades maybe yeah get that
thing moving on you'll take though i don't i don't
know if you will yep king a1 totally reasonable
seven seconds oh man i know she could
all disposition but ah this the time
was so bad very good move knight d4 the
king is uh always back rank issues on a1
all right we're gonna see how well she
can play just one second for move she
has a great chance here in my opinion yes great
chance greg is going to look to be tricky here
he's down upon and even if he wasn't down upon
his position is not good that king is vulnerable
all right okay uh i think i like that move
it was a blunder but i i don't know why that
was a blender i liked it yeah i mean it probably
has to do with this because uh rook takes f7 is
going to lead to a checkmate oh wow so she does
this and there's knight takes e6 here with check
so that's probably why but uh it didn't i agree
it looked it looked energetic it looked okay but
wow oh my goodness but it it's the time man so
you take the mask off i was right i was right
and i was also right you were right about the
bombs that well actually i think she got into
a good position so maybe the pawns helped her but
the time was the best i was right about that but i
mean i said it would be taken off before uh 12
minutes true truth we're both right i think we
both had a feeling that was coming straight off
we're both in the right for both of the the bits
whether the pawn structure was good and whether
the mask would come off yeah but greg is leaving
is on we're we're getting all the wins out
here we yeah alexandra needs to be getting
these now yeah true we need to pass on some of
our luck or good intuition his mask is off too
maybe he saw alexandria he was like oh no i got
a match i think greg just likes matches matching
he's a showman you know what looks best for the
stream guys calm yourselves this is not strip
chest those are just masks okay they're taking
off masks that's all oh my all right let's see
what is this opening grunfeld this is new
right we haven't seen this yeah i'm trying
to think did we prepare the grunfeld i don't know
if we did i don't think we did i don't know if we
did either yeah true nobody knows so let's find
out but she has to be learning from that speed
well um what we see here is a big thing from
alexandra already in the opening bishop d5
check i'm guessing she's going to
take that uh it's fourth to take and i
i why can't she just play a move like knight
f3 defending everything absolutely she can
absolutely spend too much time looking for
tricks again when she's playing the natural moves
one thing about knight f3 so like let's say
takes knight takes um if you go knight f3 i
guess greg might take on d4 and if you have to
take with the pawn it's yeah it's a fine position
but it is a weakness exactly it is a weakness
yeah sometimes the isolated pawn can be i always
learn it's either strength or weakness because
sometimes it's not very if you can defend it it
can end up being quite strong but yep she also had
to double check that she wasn't losing a bishop
to queen e4 check she would have bishop e3 and
now she's castled so look it might be a weakness
might not be the best i think greg is happy with
this position but yeah she's out of the opening
she's not like you know at 30 seconds we're
just getting down a minute we need to know
speed we need if i was there i'd be like sweet
sweet speed i'd be telling her reminding her but
yeah that that's what you need
you need a good buddy a good wings
exactly all right yeah it's still a
pretty comfortable position like you
know she has isolated pawn i guess he's
probably gonna bring like a rook d8 but
yep so i i like bishop h6 as a move um trade off
that bishop try to get the queen out there as well
that is a very nice idea i i feel like it's kind
of hard to find i don't think she'd see it b3 nice
covering c4 um so here i want to avoid trades
if i'm white end game good for greg very good
for greg why were you suggesting bishop h6 if you
want to avoid trades i should say i want to avoid
uh major peace trades it's a better clarification
so queens and rooks i'd like to keep on the board
uh so this trade might actually be good for
her then yep yeah i definitely like it because
now the dark skies around the king are weak and
her queen is easily set up and so is her knight
so she she might have an attacking plan there it
goes there we go yeah i think she might have just
jumped in with that queen a little bit early um i
would like to see the rooks build up maybe double
i'd also really like to see h4 h5 i'd like to push
that pawn up the board yep i think here with down
a minute she has to go for the natural moves that
would be a very nice plan though so i'd like to
move the queen and play h4h5 that's basically
my plan i wonder i think she'll find it maybe
she normally finds those type of plans especially
because she knows in time pressure you just need
to find a way to create another attack so she
uses that plan a lot you know brooks c2 would
be a funny blender here dropping a whole rook on
d8 but he's not nope he doesn't greg never misses
the tactics except that one beginner bishop g4
like he never misses them except yeah except once
knight h2 so aggressive idea knight g4 looking to
attack those squares and sometimes after knight
g4 you can even like sack on d5 with the rook
and you know like use the the oh yeah and try
to fork but he's preventing it right away yep and
he's looking to play rook c to d8 and attack the
d4 pawn rook b5 i really don't like that move it's
just you attack upon it gets defended what did you
what did you really do there exactly i think maybe
she should ride like well i guess that the h movie
the h pawn plan doesn't work anymore because of
the knight on f6 so she couldn't have even played
queen g3 and h4 so knight d5 here it's just
such a funny move because now the rook on
b5 is literally trapped like it's just not a6 is
going to win the rook alexander's rook b5 was like
completely the wrong idea yeah a5 and then let's
say if a6 you technically lose your rope yeah
a5 but at least she could sack for the night and
try to win the pawn yep she should take on b6 here
just to be tricky he couldn't wonder he should
just move the rook to b8 and then i think it's
just she's down a minute again like i think if
he had equal time she could probably swindle but
this one minute oh like it's it's happening again
yep she's thinking so much it's just the pawn we
don't have time yeah this unfortunately her queen
ended up on h4 which like blocked her big plan of
h48 yeah exactly and now that the knight was
gone that plan would have been very useful
so move the rook up maybe like rookie four
or key four rook f4 rook h4 unfortunately an
hg5 doesn't really make any threats rookie
four king h2 i like that as well just yeah
oh my goodness these two seconds yeah and there
goes that's so so rough i'm curious where she's
losing all her time it seems to be like in the
middle game but every game ends up being and i do
it so much myself as well yeah it's definitely in
the opening the middle game it is it is very early
on and it's if that's where it creeps up on you
you don't even notice it sometimes until the last
30 seconds yeah and then you're like wait oh i'm
down a whole minute yep that always happens to me
well i whenever i'm streaming i like to
blame the chat you know i was just trying
to play in the chat always blame the chat
but hang on your partner or the chat it's
never your fault for losing on time it's always
someone else's fault for distracting you but
unfortunately alex doesn't have anyone to
blame on this round yeah unfortunately the
camera's on but she's not exactly streaming so
it doesn't count she'd blame me if i was there
and uh i can see greg's got the the reflection of
the board in his glasses so yeah just trying to
study the position through them that's interesting
what do we have here another isolated pawn for
alexandra but i recognize this i'm pretty sure
this is more or less theory she's getting faster
she's finally playing the the first 10 moves
quicker yep she knows this position i can tell
and now uh maybe knight e3 yeah hitting the pawn
on d5 getting active there also maybe intending
knight f5 hitting the g7 pawn and the bishop on e7
which i think greg would be happy to capture yeah
and the amount of time left in the three
minute portion is just around four minutes
now andrea so wow it could be the last game
race probably is the last game in that case
yeah but in case they finish with 10 seconds
left and they start a new one it will count oh
interesting yeah but i don't think i mean
let's say one of them alex gets under last
seconds i'll be three minutes and greg will
definitely spend more than a minute on the game
so i think he'll be the last one but i really
hope alex can maybe pull you know she's off to
a better start maybe she can end on a win
go into the bullet portion feeling better
yep absolutely c3 uh by greg now alexander's
position is not bad but it's just one of those
isolated pawn positions where it's easy to get
into this funk of like i don't really know what
to do and then you start overthinking it and all
she needs to do is is for example the move she did
that's fine 96 that's a good move just need more
of that just gotta have more confidence yeah i
feel like she does just have some pawn weaknesses
like the b7 pawn and her pawns aren't reconnected
so bishop e5 threat uh d5 pawn and she's meeting
that with an active response bishop c5 saying look
you can't take that because then f2 is hit as
a result that's a nice move i like bishop c5
and um positions are very difficult yeah you
just have to play slowly i think here just slow
improving moves i don't even know here what you
should do maybe it's like rookie eight and wait
yeah rookie eight i think he's a fine move uh i
don't know b6 uh queen d7 oh but she wants to be
aggressive okay yep she's hitting f2 but um if
the knight takes on e6 she has no problem like
taking back with the pawn connecting her
pawns and solving her isolated pawn issue
yep okay i don't think g3 was a good choice for
him you know we talked about it a few times dark
dark squared bishop don't want to put your
pawns there okay and queen but maybe it's a
strength okay okay now after f4 i think that
she's basically got queen g6 as a mean option
all the way back to d8 ah this one is a one move
fork it is a one move after this one what after f5
i think there's queen g5 to like sort of stay in
the game yeah but i don't think i don't think we
can i think h4 after queen g5 is the
killer move yeah yeah i think it's h4
and now the queen is almost has to go back to e7
now if she keeps speed though you know it's just
a pawn for a knight if she if she plays this
faster like here she obviously has no other
squares in e7 so she should play it quickly
and keep her time advantage yeah i mean now
is what greg is thinking about but he's just gonna
take the piece and i think go queen g4 afterwards
queen g4 hits e6 hits g7
oh i don't know why she didn't
take because queen g queen g4
i guess there's not many ways to
defend the pawn otherwise in trade
yeah i think she's intending g5 here or i hope
she is because it sort of looked like that was her
plan just get trapped the bishop but unfortunately
like g4 yeah there's queen g4 there's knight takes
d5 there's knight f5 there's like a lot of
night jumps together yeah i think taking
on e6 was pretty important to defend that d5 pawn
and well there's 24 seconds left oh well we might
have time for it really depends alexander's
got 13.3 there's 16 seconds left ticking down
six seconds i don't think she'll resign in the
next 16 seconds no okay so there's gonna there's
gonna be no more games this is gonna be the last i
mean i don't know three minute game yeah oh oh may
as well end with a is she going to resign after
this she can resign or she's going to play on
she's going to let out a little smurf no it's
time time is up already oh that was so close
so we started the five minute portion with the
protest gambit and we ended three minutes all
style points just for style now in her defense
i will point out that the bishop was on c5 the
whole game pinning the knight and i think she
just forgot at the very end she moved it to d6
and yeah that's why she played queen e6 but hey
there's there's no excuses for focusing true
yeah you know it's it's gonna be her time to
swindle i'm telling you the bullet portion she's
gonna shine i know it okay well you heard it here
first guys from you know one beautiful speaking
about another she's gonna shine in the bullet
the score is currently 16 points for alexander
beautes she started with 15 points handicapped
she got a win in that was a big momentum shift
she needed that to make this close she's up
by one again she's still leading though yes
exactly she's in the lead point team alexandra
and after this we get into the very exciting
bullet portion one minute chess one minute for
the whole game plus one second increment per move
so we will be back with that very exciting format
to determine the winner here in this match between
alexander beautes and greg shahadi so don't
go anywhere we'll be right back after this
and welcome back everybody hopefully uh everyone
who was here before the break is still here and
ready for the bullet potion but before we get
into that i just wanted to remind everybody that
chess.com puzzle week which i was uh reminding
andrea about might be a good idea for alexandra
um yeah honestly for the both of us well boy do
i have the thing for you andrea january 4th to
uh is going to be puzzleweek on chess.com um you
know for those that are basically in vacation mode
and have no idea what day it is that is tomorrow
so mark your calendars there's basically going to
be all sorts of different versions of the
chess.com puzzles there's tactics there's
puzzle rush there's so many different ways to
do puzzles on chess.com survival mode etc and
over the five days there's going to be different
formats featured it's going to be your favorite
commentators such as danny wrench bigfoot who's
been commentating a lot for chess.com and the one
and only maurice ashley so you can see there just
some of your favorite streamers on screen there's
going to be lots lots more but it'll just be sort
of like a fun week andrea with uh you know good
good uh puzzles for for everyone and practice that
honestly we all need yeah you can watch with them
and train with them at the same time yeah yeah so
that'll be fun that's starting tomorrow but right
now we have uh they are changing every scene
every every round look at that the the outfit
outfit changes and it looks like greg for the one
minute section he he is ready to that makes sense
you know this is gonna be the most uh difficult
workout of the entire match so you gotta get
in your right workout gear yep oh great greg is
looking looking d's right there and we're we're
into it one minute plus one second all of his
crossfit training just for this bullet match
yeah is that a shoulder or a bicep no i know who
knows jeez greg's 2500. all right and it's begun
the speed it's coming strong let's see yeah and
i i already like alexandra's opening just because
i don't see any issue with it this is all she
needs yes this is all she needs we just we have
this isolated pawn game after game but you know
maybe it's not gonna be weakness in this game
the bishop p3 is very interesting i don't know
if it's good to allow him to take but i guess i
would solve the isolated pawn yep and you guys
can see just by the ratings featured on screen
uh the bullet section is gonna be a lot
closer exactly as as indicated here 23.77
25 22. yeah which if if there wasn't a one point
difference like it could have been very equal but
with almost equal odds it's still a little bit
rough but you know alex is very quick so maybe
she'll the underdog will pull through yeah the
queen b6 check uh looking to take on b2 yeah
here greg's tactics will definitely be shining
through also so i think that it's really risky
to take this pawn uh not only is d6 in the
cards but there's rook b1 and after rook b1
the queen has to take on a3 and then there's like
knight d5 exactly so i i kind of like this yeah
it totally underestimated the point
of the the strength of that past pawn
i wonder if no 97 would just be a draw given the
queen for the two rooks okay and there is going
to be queen d4 now i think she wants knight e7
here yeah that's why she tried to block this file
and he can't take there goes his rook so
he's just going to leave the knight there
and i think she's going to take that
back yeah she's got a strong defunct
but she has to watch out for dark squares
bishop bishop bishop has won queen g3
she's got to move the king there you go good no
no queen g1 much much better than king i think
okay i'm a little concerned rook to b1 is what
greg wants she's going to continue defending
very quick and she does have a little bit of a
time edge which never really happened so far so
wow now this is this is looking very promising
yep now i think she should take the rook and
then solve her queen like her queen being on
g1 she can't move it it's a non-participant
there we go can i say i wonder if you could grab
that a7 pawn yep nice this is good because now
everything around our king is descended that
bishop is holding it all together black doesn't
have any threats yep and the black bishop is stuck
on like don't let alexandria get a queen duty on
yes exactly it's acting like a pawn this however
um i think queen e7 is gonna be played yes bishop
no we're gonna lose our main strength the
past pawn and she's spending her time okay
it's okay there's another one yeah
we got another one just replace them
yep unfortunately if she loses that then
it really is gonna be tough bishop c4
just keeping the pressure on f7 very important
yep just you should just go back and forth because
i don't think you would want the draw she just
went back to before oh she blundered her bishop
she forgot that this oh man ah she's doing so well
it's just these little blunders but let's be clear
alexandra and this bullet uh portion is gonna be
way more competitive like this is going to be very
close i think as you can see yep and even here i
don't know well no okay this one's over now never
mind yeah the best you could hope for is some sort
of stalemate but yeah don't see it happening yep
well i i thought she should have just
went back to b5 instead of bringing her
queen down after that rook attack tried
to repeat moves to save her time right
and is he finally going to move that pawn up
the board oh queen f4 struggling to get to the
checkmate yeah he's i don't know what he's doing
he seems a little scared of the time ticking down
he's like always making a move to get more time
yeah exactly oh all right she resigned the other
i guess i'm checking me too was coming so
that's only game one it's 16 all right now
all right now it really starts now it really
starts here we go greg with the white pieces
alexandra going for the fiance king's indian
style i i liked a lot how she played that last
game but of course she is more likely to blunder
than greg so and blunders bullet is known for that
yep and this is gonna be a position where i think
he's gonna take the knight with the bishop on
g5 and then reroute this knight the long way to
like e1 c2 e3 d5 something like that interesting
you don't think is he gonna occupy the d5
squares with his knight i think that's the
plan i was gonna say he's probably gonna toss
in b4 on the way to that idea but yeah i think
eventually ending up on d5 is the plan yep now
the two knights are strong defending each other
yeah these positions i always try to keep the
light square diagonal blocked because as soon
as you open it up white's g2 bishop is just
too strong while ours is still locked in by e5
yeah so this move a6 i don't think
alexandra needed to play it at all like
i don't think there's any need i think she
should go on the other side f5 like f5 yeah
did you use your bishops over there yes i think
you know a6 you wanted to stop knight b5 knight
b5 would you try to trade your bishop for the
knights or just continue defending try to defend
if i could do it i would always try to not give up
my my light square bishop where it possibly yeah
that that's why and i kind of understand
a6 because just allowing that night b5
looks like you're giving them space but
that would have also stopped rook b6
d3 is threatened there's a one move attack
bishop on c6 is super solid right here by
the way guarding everything uh she kind of had
this in her last game with the bishop on f3 so
this is good we need to see more king side
pressure f5 but that's solid solid strategy here
i think she wanted to play f5 and she was like
wait my queen's honestly yeah exactly let me move
that out of the way but now see going back and
forth might make him make some mistakes because
i trading the bishop should be a little bit
better for her and that knight is also cutting
off his rook so i think her going back and
forth maybe inclined him to play a little bit
weaker yeah this is this is fine for for alexander
she's getting and i knew that he was gonna sack
there right why did he do that because he's
a bullet yep very true ah and she's half the
sign and there's the tactics there's the rook
right back yep and eyes up upon okay well now
this is now they're going to take on a6 this is
very rough she could try like yup f4 some bullet
tricks but there's not much there going you really
know your sister yeah she could try this nonsense
f4 yep there it is just to like you know give
a check and hope he messes and misses something
that's the bullet strategy but we know greg is
a bit more of a defensive passive player when
he sees the clean on f5 he plays f3 the eval
bar just dropped oh my goodness take the rook
queen makes b8 and queen check
and there's a draw oh my god
she mouse slipped oh no she
dropped her look and then a queen
you know what we blame this on the mouse this
wasn't oh wow they're eager to go again all right
that was really upsetting she had a draw but you
know that's a bullet there's gonna be mouse slips
oh man so i don't think it was a draw
like a perpetual shack force but it was
just her queen was gonna yeah her queen was gonna
get in there and the threat of perpetual i think
it was dead even as you said man she was so
close wow the one time she finally sees the
tactic he doesn't the mouse slip yeah so as you
can see alexandra has her chances greg even when
he's so up even when you know the f4 like bullet
trick it worked right it didn't happen in bullets
yes the so far the first two
games were very very close
another protest game but right when she had the
perpetual movie or the yeah hangings like oh
i i mean i think after black took the rook and
she didn't give the check it was already a win so
you know that boat is gamble it was just another
style point because she already knew it was lost
and i hope she's not thinking
about that uh as much as i am
i'm still thinking about the last game so
i hope she's forgotten we move on we drop a
queen you forget about it there's just normal
life around here i already forgot about it
okay so d3 hanging alexandra also down about 15
16 seconds like that's quite cool
because he has the attack here
it's interesting though because it's a blocked
position where both players have the bishops
which don't do well in blocked positions so but
this pawn structure of whites i'm not a fan of
yeah so i think i was going to say i thought she
was going to take the bishop and go bishop takes
f5 like sacked the brookfield oh that was a very
nice tactic and then take on f5 but because she
didn't do that that bishop on e4 is insanely
strong he got his bishop outside of the pawns
the most important thing here yep oof this looks
tough as soon as the rook like gets down to c2 and
the queen gets in it could be over very quick but
alexander on the attack trade yep keeping pressure
nice maybe she could try like rook c1 d6 yeah
oh yeah she's looking at d6 or maybe rook to f1
get over to make some threats 10 seconds rook f1
there's maybe bishop f6 she needs to make goodness
oh are she gonna flag what she now slipped
again a drum okay this one we do not forget okay
that's like i need to go give her my mouse i don't
know i think we have the same mouse i don't know
oh my goodness two mouse lifts in a row but i
mean luckily okay actually the last mouse slip
did throw the game but this one didn't so it's not
as devastating but you know the one of the tough
things about being known for both gambits is that
when you really do actually mouse slip people are
like yeah okay yeah exactly but there's another
protest nice try that one well sometimes i don't
see him when she plays them but that one since i
saw it at the same time i know it was a mouse slip
but we will like be playing a game and we will
both we'll be playing a team match and not even
realize we're hanging our queen together so
just another sister strength yep just remember
as long as you're on the same page it might not be
a good page but you're on the scene yeah exactly
all right trying new things every game which it's
definitely for the better since he was crushing us
in the opening lines we did know yep and in bullet
that's exactly the way you want to do things right
now she's trying to basically toss the jeep
on off the board the last moves have prepared
very interesting i like the more aggressive
idea here but he is a very good defender so
okay so rook h1 defending um queen c6 looking for
g4 and i think he's going to take that pawn yep he
has to and now knight takes he could probably
take the pawn and taking on f3 isn't a threat
but it's okay no need to spend too much time
on this well knight takes g5 rook takes h5 and
yeah i guess she's she's not too
happy with that okay so she takes it
oh i think we blundered now well i mean
rook g6 or knight knight f6 are both fine um
i think he's got a better position
but uh it is it's still playable
yeah yeah actually it wasn't a blender
okay actually maybe her tricky
line was actually better
i thought our rook would be too misplaced but
it's not too bad he's not taking that pawn
h4 i i like h4 in general yeah better
than giving it for free with no capital
definitely take it open up the g file yes take it
yeah eight seconds we need to get it i think she's
doing fine here she's down upon but she's she's
very okay it's just the time the time the time
i would make sure to play a move like king b8
or whoa and be more aggressive uh i'm not second
yeah it's gonna get checked and i bet
you will cause a flag maybe queen g5 is
a fantastic move queen takes h5 rook g8 that's
a tactic streaming for you uh she knows it too
that is a tactic rook g8 that's exactly what
you'll find in puzzle week starting tomorrow
yes it is man these games are close but it's
she's a little bit too slow he's getting still
too much of a time advantage in the beginning
yeah the thing is all of these are are close but
who's getting them that's that's what exactly
reminders that's exactly the the type of rating
difference like you can play so equal and then
just those 10 lasting moves are going to crush
you and that's where their experience shows off
yep so i think here you could consider taking on
b2 and then queen b4 check and win
the knight back on c5 that was an
interesting line yeah i think they're both not
playing their usual openings yeah just going
greg's just going for safe he's got two bishops
he's saying look i just developed yeah you can go
wrong here but it's also easy to play on white's
part he doesn't have a bishop player though
yeah a6 i mean greg is a little bit better here
uh bishops are good center is a big center but
definitely not a bad position for alexander at all
yes there should be two knights trying to push c4
or f4 or even better okay so f4 creates some
weaknesses she's got to take that yeah now
we don't have c4 anymore i don't know but
i guess she has the d file maybe push e4
unless he stops it he doesn't
know anything no he just sees
he sees my ideas way quicker than me by the time
i notice them he already knows how to stop them
king f2 okay rook there i think king does
need to go to f2 though gotta trade the rooks
i mean we're equal on time so oh no this is a
position i think alexandra can win it's just
put that knight on d4 she's done it and now you
realize like it's not easy at all to break through
with the bishops i think alexandra can improve
her king move the knight from g3 maybe play h3 g4
h3g4 i like it no i think i think she can
do well in this position knights are really
nice to play with siri went off she always
okay she's looking to participate as well
i mean you know with a.i and chess stream siri
might just be the next big chess player oh
greg's rerouting i think she needs to leave her
king on f2 h3g4 yes we need there we go king f2
okay h3 h3 g4 she gonna do it oh my
goodness no she doesn't see the plan
i think she's trying to occupy the holes or
something she doesn't really know what to do
like maybe she's going back and forth which is
fine as long as she's not wasting too much time
okay no not the plan you wanted but it's
a solid flynn because the dark the darkest
bishop can't really get in and attack that v2
pawn so she's got to keep this close okay so
she's just turtling she's saying look yeah
i i respect i respect the turtle but yeah
he has that file again we don't have rook h1 oh
my goodness no no no no no knight f3 united three
knight f3 is a good move actually that
is a good one g4 thank you okay she got
out of it i don't think you should have
taken on before it should have taken on g3
yeah i think black should have taken on g3 didn't
happen okay take that back i see three i like it
she's she's coming out of the darkness but two
seconds oh my goodness there's knight a4 as well
knight she could pretty much before would have
been a nice premium yes okay quite fast there
we go we just need speed take it home take the win
oh but he hasn't passed the master doesn't matter
get the knights back yes take something yes
yes geek there we go he dropped off now she's
got it now she's got it he gobbling it all up
finally a bullet win we knew she had it she just
needed to break through nice hey look at those
juicy points grayson quite a lot of rating if
he loses two more you could go underneath 2500
well that is that's a big win for alexander 19
to 17. now andrea let's also remember this match
is getting close but look at the time yeah how
much time do we have six and a half minutes oh
wow two if she could win two in a row yep that'd
be fantastic but yeah 16 minutes is not much but
you know it's bullet that's plenty of games yes
six minutes oh sorry six minutes yes yes so that
is not a lot you said 16 no so there's six months
never mind it's okay we have time for two wins yep
she's well she's got exactly that and she needs
to do exactly that come on just win the tune well
at least it's competitive you know it's close okay
and i don't mind this you know what happened last
time with that okay file it kind of worked out um
before i don't mind this for alexandra basically
when alexandra is attacking greg i i always think
she's gonna do a bit better i agree for sure
h5 he is a very strong defender but
it's much better than her defending yep
yep brooke g8 threatens knight h4 yeah i think
safe castle is a good idea here is to avoid
as long as she and she's keeping her time which
is giving me lots of hope yep i really like when
she's attacking she's getting good positions
good positions i like that move knight age four
threat h5 go go page five let's go looking
good she's got a very good position yes
now if h4 i think he's going to go g4 queen
h3 i'm fine with that move aggressive no
i'm going to queen trade and take f5 with
the knight beautiful attacking the pawns
this is very good oh i thought she had something
really good there was you got a tactic or
something i don't mind f6 b4 is hanging here as
well she's also got like just doubling the ropes
solid yep and that knight is very strong
there's a really good play by alexandria
doubling the rooks it's looking good knight back
probably gonna bring the rook back to g1 here
i was wondering here if she could play
knight h3 yep knight h3 you're right
very good tactic that actually would have been
fantastic attacking both the rooks forcing rook to
f1 and then she could brought rogue oh that would
have been rook two two and it doesn't won the game
it's okay uh take it back she's still got a great
position yeah she just has to activate her king
i think you can take away yeah she
can take on e4 because we're not
worried about the pin because we
have knight c3 right or even check
he's thinking he's getting down he's going down
10 seconds alexandra activate the king maybe or
she wants to trade even well has the file but
let's just eat up the pawns yep i like that move
this is good you're gonna take one c4 she can grab
the pawn she's used to trying to use the knight to
grab all makes sense because the rook is important
on f4 holding the king there and greg's going to
go a5 next but oh she's she's playing this really
well she is playing this really well you got to
watch fun oh this is so nice one more pawn okay
yeah she does have to watch the h pawn for sure oh
king h3 she needs the night night in the
bring the knight yeah because the rook
doesn't have really enough time to get behind
the pawn or does it end there we go there we go
all right so she's winning here she's just four
seconds though she has four seconds i don't
i don't know mr mike plug run the pawn nice nice
good now the rook can run h4 beautiful she hung
her knight that's okay she slows chances king
don't eat it have enough pawns to win but one
second oh my god she's so close to flagging
okay she's back to three oh god the time is
making me so nervous oh my gosh there's rook h3
check oh before it won the night oh no no no
it's a drama take the knight take the knight
take the night five seconds oh no no no take the
knight take the gun ignite and then check and then
prepare the queen but it's too late oh my goodness
check it out i don't know what's gonna happen
he's gonna take a draw or something no she's
like probably still winning or something yes yes
he has a lot of pawns oh gosh b4 before
it's main two b4 no it was made in two oh
man oh no okay it's still it's still not over it's
still tied looks tied is she gonna be able to meet
him king c3 very nice knight d5 he has b3 b3 yes
25 or 94 b2 king b3 oh this is a draw but she
shouldn't take it technically with the patch yeah
no he's gonna go for it she's gonna go for a trick
she has to dang it i think i think
that means she's gonna lose the match
even though it's a tremendous game point that's
insane just because there's not enough time
wow but you know even being one
point away is a pretty strong finish
wow wow that game guys i mean you saw that
was a great game andrea and i was literally
just screaming because there were like maids
miss pieces everywhere that's bullet though
that's why it's a lot of fun how much time do we
have on the timer a minute and 20 seconds dang
yeah that's what i was saying bad games
unfortunately she had to win that yeah
yep she had her chances it's okay at least
if we finish with a win a 0.5 difference
is not too bad yeah yeah greg greg looks like he's
gonna win this match but you know there's there's
one more game and alexandra ellis finished wrong
finish with dignity she's playing really well
right now yes i i told you that the bullet i knew
was gonna be a strong suit but this is so close
i think if there was no increment on the bullet
it would have been different because she would
have had her dirty flags yes but uh i don't know
who would have flagged first true i don't know
i know she's she has a lot of
tricks up her sleeves so does greg
so c3 uh kick the knight up bishop g5 coming
in she's got a great position by the way yep
yeah this is a fantastic guy i love it
her king is safe her rooks are well placed
and her development is just great yeah bishop g5
i love the position this is this is nice
um 97 and forcing the trade so that she can
bring a rook to the seventh rank yep this
looks really good do it right now oh maybe
yeah 97. this is okay take with the bishop maybe
and try to win that pawn or take her to the right
she could win ah there's not enough time
so i think the idea is like um c4 here
then to play bishop d5 check and bishop h6 after
king h8 and you have a very almost checkmate
wow um but after after c4 there
is queen takes b2 so it's nice
not so simple she wants to get her bishop
to d5 that would have been a fantastic she
got a stacked on g7 then push c4 and yeah g7
bishop h6 get the bishop to d5 that's oh my god
yeah bishop or rook back to e7
she's trading don't like that
okay okay uh king up and now we do not want
to trade no trades uh not much of a choice
what oh now the king can easily defend yeah so
greg just has the upper hand here in the end game
um up a pawn often in the end game that's
enough to win yes especially when they both
have the bishop pair and they'll they'll trade
off and end up with the same colored bishop
no chance for draw and there was a moment there
where greg could have just repeated moves and
taken a draw and won the match and he's like
yeah he's like you know what at the rate yeah
reading matters yeah that's very
true hey bishop c1 by alexandra
grandmaster move to finish off there we go
nice i'm a fan bishop f1 maybe for the fans
bishop f1 for the fans no okay she's just
avoiding all the bishop trades makes sense
yep exactly what you should do yep
so now eventually she's gonna run out the back
and forth moves because yep he's coming to attack
king b5 probably king a4 okay there we go now
the king is kind of cut off from entering back
can you go around bishop c6 take on a5 no they
could have taken the pawn oh yeah with with jeff
yeah or taking the bishop and then taking the pawn
oh that would have been a nice draw or maybe i'll
yeah he has three seconds alexander
could have maybe won that position yeah
this still can happen doubles you down to
kwanzaa whoa bishop d6 is good interesting
but i'm defending the night's still tough he's
got one second by the way yeah alexandra is
very quick yes she really is looking good she
might put it she's keeping the pressure nice
a great move yeah maybe oh no why d1 okay she
can't take on g6 she's gonna take eight and
now she hey okay we're gonna get a draw maybe
this is a probably a draw uh should be a draw
but she's nearly trying to mate
herself king e2 yeah oh god oh no
that is a beautiful checkmate to to end
off a half wow just half point everyone's
saying oh these odds they're not fair
clearly it was tied it was very close
oh my goodness that that was a beautiful
checkmate yes that was great i i loved the
ending even though i would have loved to see the
rook sack in c4 but this is a great match i i knew
it'd be off to the bullet but greg very well done
to greg yeah that was beautiful so the match does
finish uh 19 and a half to 18 and a half for
uh international master greg shahadi probably
as close as it could be greg was you know careful
not to go 16-0 handicap because he wouldn't have
won that in that case that was insanely close
yeah oh i didn't realize there's a one point
difference i thought she had oops i thought she
had more never mind i wasn't yeah i know that
but it's just i can't do math i just thought she
had another win for some reason no it's it's very
close though it's just one game and after that
exciting match uh we're looking forward to getting
into an interview with the players but before we
do that just gonna take a super short break to
get that set up and to give everyone a chance to
cool down after that you know adrenaline packed
uh one minute section so andrea you and i will
be right back after this short break with the
interview
and welcome back everybody we are joined by
the competitors in today's match alexandra
botes and greg shahadi and andre and i were
honestly on the edge of our seats because
the the handicap that was given i'll go to you
first greg honestly made it such a perfect match
it was so close in the end just one game
separating it is this handicap uh you know
do you have any idea what this 15 games was
gonna mean like do you always be this close
i really didn't know i thought i would do
well in the first two sections um you did
and i go into the last one i think i was
what up one point or even or something
and i was like okay one minute chest should be
no problem and then at the end she just starts
beating me then i'm getting checkmated it won't
let me move any pieces like the king of stuff
and then i looked and i was like time as i was
like okay get me out of here yeah thank goodness
that that one point at the end alexandria you
were mounting a pretty serious comeback in the
bullet portion and i think uh andre and i were
both agreeing that as the time got shorter your
your chances of winning were going to get higher
did you feel the same way coming into this match
uh i i i told greg that i was really nervous
coming to this match i felt like i was going
to get kind of wiped off the board but at
least the bullet portion wasn't as bad i
mean i hope i scared greg a little bit you
know that's all i can hope for i'm terrified
i was so happy i don't know how much time was
left and then you could be i was like oh my god
what's happening and then i looked and i was
like okay i mean i was scared yeah andrea do
you have any uh anything you'd like to say
to your sister after she represented house
uh botes there do you think cameron would be
proud after that match i think the one win
in the five minute or three minute section that
he prepared me in that one line he must be yeah
yeah i promised hammer i wouldn't let him down
and i did where you will have a chat oh man that's
this is a this is a serious interview all of a
sudden alexander is going to get chatted to after
oh yeah well that was a beautiful game though
the the one that you're talking about um uh
there was actually some serious prep remembered
there by alexandra and that game was actually
quite important for the match because it
gave you a lot of confidence i thought
and going into the bullet i think people kind
of underestimated maybe what what you could
do in the bullet section was quite impressive
alexandra but i'm going to ask you what's on the
tip of everyone's tongue right now uh did you guys
coordinate outfits during that or you know what's
what's going on that was so coordinated alexandra
greg helped me out here oh it was all improvising
improvisation like once you did the thing with
the hat i'm just like i'm changing my outfit every
year i like that greg would always match respect
greg you pulled out the mask frankie's super
fashionable he brought out the blazer so i had to
bring one out also you know if i can't beat him in
chess at least match him in his fashion i don't
know if the the future opponents are going to be
changing outfits as much as alex but i hope so
i hope so we got a lot of different looks from
you guys we got masks we got the hat the workout
attire there was plenty i was i think oh go on
greg i gotta do a quick workout in between the
three minute and one minute section that's why
yeah yeah you were wearing your muscle tank top
we're like was he working out before this alex
only brought out the dumbbell once maybe that
was the whole one game decisive because he was
exercising a little bit more that's because
you are streaming and i was kicked out of my
own house and i'm playing in a little conference
room and i got to go all the way up to go to the
bathroom i don't have time to exercise that's
true that's true i heard andrea giving behind
the scenes advice to alexandra you know during
the breaks and it was something to the effect of
alexandra just don't blunder tactics and you'll
win no i said very wise words i said don't go
for tricks play solid but you know it means the
same thing yeah yeah just don't lose in your win
exactly exactly just don't blend with that better
at tactics like you can't just change your style
yeah greg's tactics were super sharp greg
thank you do you do a lot of puzzles i've
been doing some puzzle rush lately that's
what we're lacking yeah my image of greg
is him doing crossfit and then doing like
five chest and then a couple more reps
yeah that's that's like pretty act well now that's
everyone's you've been watching my workout routine
you know i am greg i'm taking notes well you
practically did one uh on cam for us here so we
couldn't help it we couldn't help it now greg
the the end result was you know i got to say
congratulations you did come away with a victory
against alexandria so you will move on to the next
round in this tournament um now you've you've got
some experience in this event before so you played
in the last i am not a gm tournament um and this
time around it's a little bit different it's not
all ims it's some popular faces streamers um what
do you think that does to the nature of the event
because already we saw how much fun it was to
have a handicap and you are ever the entertainer
first i want to say one thing um if you look at
the bracket there's one name that's not there
there's one scared player that knew
he was going to get whooped this year
like i'm not playing i don't want any piece
of greg shahadi you know who that is right
mr john bartholomew and that's one game i played
with handy in his honor just to be like you know
you didn't play the scandi like the whole
match against me i'm going to play it
to show you you know like i'm not a chicken
that's all i want to say yeah harsh words for john
and uh yeah a lot of i love that danny wrench
lawrence trent match that's going to be amazing
ooh yeah yeah that was one of my highlights
as well uh an underrated matchup danny
against lawrence is going to be some some heat
behind that one yeah a lot of matches coming up
andrea do you have any uh anything you wanna i
know you're gonna have your talk with with alex
so maybe you're saving your questions for office
i'll save my words for alex but greg well played
i love that thank you congratulations on winning
the match and good luck in the next matchup
thank you very much thanks so much for
everything great match alex it was fun
yeah greg i had a lot of fun uh thanks for this
i know i know you're obviously the much better
player but it whenever i have a match like this
it makes me want to play more chess and study
more so i appreciate it you're a very strong
player so you play a lot of really good games
especially in the end of that bullet and you
know like early in the five minute there was
some tough like the second game the fourth game
they were like time scrambles i was like i'm
gonna lose the second game but i didn't somehow
yeah it was like pulled it off yeah somehow the
uh the result ended in greg's favor but i agree
that the games that we saw and the way we were
commentating the time scrambles i mean we didn't
know what was gonna happen so thanks to both of
you greg congratulations again alexandra thank
you so much that was a truly entertaining match
and i think i speak for andrea the chat everyone
uh watching that we really had a great time so
um ggs and we'll see you in the next round greg
yeah thank you thanks andreas thanks bye everyone
all right bye guys and uh that is
gonna be our uh our coverage here
for the i i'm not a gm tournament um chess.com
puzzle week don't forget that is starting tomorrow
you know in terms of chess.com events and what to
look forward to that's coming right up so if you
if you didn't get enough chess today don't worry
we got you covered for tomorrow and uh andrea the
the chess.com arena kings also gets underway the
week after that so you know if you're basically
looking to just get immersed in chess.com events
i think it's fair to say we got the people covered
yes there's definitely some very exciting events
coming up and i will be watching the puzzle one
because both alex and i need the practice yeah
so puzzles coming up that's starting tomorrow
it's gonna be a lot of fun as i mentioned lots
of different formats that we're gonna get into
uh andrea i mean did it hurt a little bit watching
your sister go down on you know on live twitch tv
you know i knew that greg had very good odds so
overall i'm pretty proud because it was a very
close very close matchup so i'm proud with how it
ended yeah and speaking of how it ended you know
she got a beautiful checkmate there on the board
so hey you can't complain it was a match that greg
was the favorite in uh ever the entertainer he he
put up a handicap and it was a super close match
and uh you know congrats to him but i think uh
he'll be looking forward to his next match and
we'll be looking forward to to commentating uh
future matches so it's been a pleasure today
thanks for yeah it was great um thank you so much
for being a great partner and i will be cheering
greg on in the future rounds i'm a big greg
fan after this commentary for sure awesome well
thanks for hanging out with us guys we're done
for the day thanks for watching the coverage of
greg shahadi versus alexandra botes in the i'm not
a gm tournament and this tournament is going to be
going on for uh months actually there's going
to be lots of matches keep in touch uh always
stay following the channel there's gonna be lots
of coverage and puzzle week starts next week so
without further ado andrea thanks again and uh bye
everybody see you next time thank you i'm on bye
everybody